holy crap it's happening
so much welcome to fat man beyond i'm
kevin smith
i'm mark bernard hey
um here we are uh in separate places of
course because as you know
the world is one big fat corroded mess
right now
with with uh did you they used to say
that when you were in school where
people that was like the big
uh [ __ ] curse when we were kids
before anyone introduced me to the term
[ __ ]
which was matthew creedon in first grade
who said it to me
on the playground and then i asked miss
beatty our teacher i was like what does
[ __ ] mean she goes if you say it again
i'll kick in the shins
and then i was like what does shin what
are shins because i didn't know what
that was either
i was [ __ ] six mark but before that
the big curse that you could lay down on
anybody was like you're corroded
you're corroded oh she's [ __ ]
corroded
you're corroded and [ __ ] so i remember
that i think it went hand in hand with
grody it was like corroded more 80s than
than 70s but yeah right grody is i guess
grody is a kind of uh derivation of of
corroded to some degree
yeah you know children welcome to
language and nomenclature
kevin and mark here we just we go into
etymology of words and try to figure out
what things mean
we're gonna geek the [ __ ] out kids
there's so much news uh to go over
uh here on fat man beyond isn't there a
mark too much
i mean i don't know i guess a thing
happened
a thing happened and then kept happening
man like
warner brothers as we remember last week
came out was like
we're putting our old 2021 slate on hbo
max and then this week disney plus was
like
hold my beer and suddenly everything
has been announced so we have lots to go
over however
thank the lord in these lean times um we
actually have not just one
but two sponsors tonight two isn't that
right mark
indeed um the first one uh and i think
we'll break it up so we don't give you
guys this wall-to-wall uh ad gasm
uh first one is native dealer
we like the natives
[Music]
this is their uh christmas candy cane
flavor right there as you could see now
native deodorant
oh ooh
smell just like candy cane you can have
that in your armpit for heaven's sakes
let me tell you a quick story about
native deodorant these cats they've
advertised with with us once or twice a
few times before
lovely people so what folks advertise
with you
uh as mark will back me up they send you
the product so you could actually
look at it use it like in this instance
hold it up and stuff like that
so the good folks at natives sent me
deodorant
uh me deodorant this is the deodorant
that they sent
it was the uh it's just here you go
coconut
and vanilla
i did not get to use it but once
before my wife absconded with it and
said this is really good
then i went into my shower three days
later
and i found a whole compliment of
native body wash and so i assumed
mark that my you know the good folks at
native when they said this
had sent along the body wash as well
um however what i've since
come to learn from my wife is that she
liked
this so much that she actually went out
and bought this advertising on fat man
beyond works because my wife will buy
anything that we advertise apparently
anything i mean i can't think of a
better commercial for native than that i
literally i
it was given to me for free for heaven's
sakes and my wife was like no no
we will actually spend real money on it
and stuff and now she buys it it's a
regular for her it's a regular part of
her
her products if you will it's a good
thing we're not advertising range rovers
it's like thank the lord i know like
look i bought one i'm like oh
that's right we don't have that kind of
we need a few more native ads for
us um but i've been using this
[ __ ] in the shower and it is fantastic
man great company
great products that have invaded my life
not just our show
but actually came into my life on a
regular basis you
um absolutely i i have uh gone to the
end of my mint and eucalyptus
native and i'm digging into the candy
cane i feel like it's a like
kind of attractive pheromones for elves
put a little behind the ears a little
under the pits
hell yes
did we lose kev oh there he is is that
me or you freezing up
i don't know one of us did yellow
we we got you back yeah one of us froze
up
it's made a really bad internet
connection
it seems unstable yeah well
i'm just gonna start reading some native
copy do it man do it sell it
yes native is a perfect addition to your
daily holiday
daily routine this holiday season it
just doesn't block odor better
they're made better native has
ingredients you've never heard of
and also ones that you have like coconut
oil and shea butter it's also vegan
and never tested on animals and it never
uses ingredients it shouldn't be in
deodorant like aluminum
parabens sulfates or talc
the candy cane gives it what
nativedio.com
ladies and gentlemen uh slash well is it
is it fat man i assume
it is fat man native deo dot com slash
fat man
n a t i v e and then d
e o as in deodorant
uh dot com slash fat man what are they
gonna get for that
man you are gonna get
money off nice
um yeah it's funny this this copy
doesn't say exactly what they do get
with
30-day free returns and exchanges
yeah there it is shop natives holiday
collection today
ladies and gentlemen today uh by going
to nativedo.com
fat man or use the promo code fat man
at check out and get 20 off
your first order that's native d e o d e
o dot com slash fat man or use promo
code fat man at checkout
for 20 off your first order if it's good
enough for
jennifer schwabach it's good enough for
you ladies and gentlemen and there's
candy i'm gonna use this [ __ ] right now
dude yeah because
i just typed running canyon right before
the show began
i went running canyon so you know what
i'm i'm i'm probably a little a little
funky so
i'd much rather smell like christmas
goes on smooth ooh there it is there's
something we don't get to do in the
when we do the show on the bar you
rarely get to see me you know rock
personal hygiene
a little better even though you know
it's really for the underwear oh my god
i smell so festive that's nice like a
wreath around your balls
it really is man deck the halls ladies
and gentlemen and
deck your armpits right here with candy
cane native
nativedo dot com deo
uh go there and give them love man and
they'll give you 20 off you put fat man
in that box native d.o proud sponsor
uh although maybe not anymore after that
terrible ad a fat
blonde stuff nothing but something smell
good
i'm telling you i i can guarantee we
made one sale though this is proof
positive of that who buys
who buys three you know what i'm saying
isn't one body wash enough like there's
three i don't know what kind of mood
you're gonna be in
lavender rose that's the one i use
because i love lavender cucumber mint
must be
jennifer's because it's practically
empty and then there's a coconut vanilla
man but i'm all about the lavender i
love
lavender blue dilly dilly um all right
man
nativedio.com they're sponsoring us
tonight
later on we got another sponsor as well
we'll tell you about in the middle of
the news but before we even get to that
part of the show
how you been my friend what you've been
up to this week i'm doing well man i'm
doing well i uh i moved into my uh as
you can see
my secure remote location um
yeah what it looks like it looks like
you're at the daily planet from
dick donner's version of superman where
are you i am perry white no i'm at a i'm
at a wee world
installation do i keep frozen no i see
you moving oh there you froze again
and you're back um no i'm i'm in a
wework location
um out by me i rented myself a little
bit of office space i figured you know
i'm making a decent living and
sometimes you might need to go someplace
quiet and have a little fortress of
solitude
it's smaller than the other guys but
it's getting the job done
what is the uh they must be giving
[ __ ] deals right now right are you
alone in that we work space
um you know on a saturday at 4 00 p.m
yeah
i'm kind of alone but even most days it
ain't crowded
um so yeah they they were able to knock
off the the monthly price quite a bit
because there's not a ton of folks
looking to rove in and get off of space
yeah they're not a sponsor but heavens
folks if you're looking for some cheap
office space right now
now's the time wework is the place to go
i mean they got to fill
those buildings um so what do you do
when you're alone you can't
masturbate in the wework office there's
glass everywhere so do you actually work
in your office that
i have an office all i do is masturbate
it sounds like you actually
i'm working although you know there's a
world in which you know having glass all
around you and having people watch is
that you're precisely your thing
um it is not mine though so yeah it's a
lot of writing lots of zoom calls
um the occasional podcast like today um
but it's good it's good couple hours a
day to be able to just get in here and
have some peace and quiet
is uh is doing a body good for sure
nicely nicely um i keep getting a uh
thing on my my computer telling me my
internet is unstable
so apologies kids i'm i'm about as close
to the router as i could get so i don't
know what the [ __ ] going on
just goes to show you that you know
you could be a 26-year veteran in this
business
um you know having you could even work
for netflix
as i do making masters universe and
still
if you live in the hollywood hills
you're just gonna get [ __ ] internet it's
that bad
jason muse lives around the block for me
and he's a constant streamer of course
as we know over his twitch channel but
he lives and dies by
internet signal and he barely likes to
come over to my house anymore because
he's just like your signal's weak
he's always running those tests where
you do like the up and down to see how
fast it is and [ __ ] like that
so for a guy who does a lot of internet
stuff i wish i could have a stronger
connection but apparently here in the
hill is
as good as it gets so hopefully it'll
it'll last as we uh go through all there
is to go
through today i was supposed to be in
minnesota today
um minneapolis at the first avenue
uh club you know where prince and and
and uh morris day in the time fought for
stage dominance in purple rain
uh they opened up movies today the
movies pop
up and um i didn't get to go uh i was
advised
medically because of my dopey heart
condition that i should not travel i was
supposed to go to see
my mom is my mom's birthday this weekend
she turned 75 this week
so i didn't get to see mom however over
at uh movies
uh we had the debut as you can see of
the big movie costume which we just had
made man derek berry
who runs our pop-ups he's the guy inside
the suit right now
that was made by craft studios the same
folks that make outfits for the masked
singer over on fox they built this giant
movies he's
a movie outfit he's got two fan units
inside to keep the wearer cool
and stuff like that so movies been
taking pictures with everybody in my
absence in minneapolis he'll be going to
every
pop-up that we do throughout 2021
because we got a few more
lined up going into the new year who
knew that i would become a backdoor
restaurateur mark the sexiest
restaurant so um i've been doing that
uh this week i've been uh trying to get
out and go to see my mom and then
finally the door got shut down
on that which that means i didn't go to
minneapolis as well
uh but i've been working as well i
didn't get a fancy wework office but i
too have been doing a little bit of
writing this week what are you working
on is it disclosed or undisclosed
um all of it at the moment is
undisclosed
um which i know it sucks but there's
i mean look anybody who watches this
show
is just happy that we have jobs so i
think they understand if we can't
be forthcoming with details about the
various things that we've
the fingers we've got our pies in which
sounds filthier than i mean it but
there's some cool [ __ ] i know what
mark's up to and mark knows what i'm up
to
and next year like if all goes well
you know we're gonna have some very cool
things to talk about
um maybe it'll be on an investor call
from some
giant corporation who can you know maybe
yeah that's right maybe one day
we'll be involved in one of those calls
man one day
kevin foggy or kathy kennedy will be
like here's our
mega slate and you'll hear our names pop
up likely not but
always hope and it doesn't just because
we won't be you know on any disney calls
doesn't mean we ain't
got some cool jobs coming our way and
stuff so this sounds like this sounds
very much like i got a girlfriend she
lives in canada but
me and mark got some cool jobs coming up
we just can't talk about right now
mark's job's so cool look at him wasting
money on wework offices
you know he's employed for heaven's
sakes i know i i love
my many jobs in the niagara falls region
we can't see them they're up in canada
um
yes it is coming to the end of the year
man and still uh there's a little bit of
last
minute work to be done and work to be
done heading into uh
2021 so we'll be able to tell you that
more probably in the future and whatnot
yeah back on things are
things are happening things are really
happening for mark yeah
and and not to in the weird way they're
all happening and it's all great
if it all happens at the same time i'm
going to die
because there's a little bit too much so
it's like hey i hope
this one goes faster than this one does
and this one takes a good long time
because
if all these birds land at the same time
we're going to crash the airport
it's true that's the trick of this is to
spin as many plates as possible
um that way you know nothing is ever
guaranteed to happen so you figure if
you spin a bunch of plates at least
one of them might happen but the danger
is as mark says like you know if all the
chickens come home to roost at once it's
an embarrassment of riches
those would be tremendous problems
very much so um that's been happening
that i can talk about
um is i i partnered with this company
called
embattled clothing um last year we put
out a uh t-shirt the resistance is from
shirt you put out last year
um resistance is fertile yeah that's
right yeah it was the first shirt we put
out
um and they were like hey do you want to
do another one and i said yes if i can
curse on it
and they said what do you mean curse and
i says well i want to use the worst
curse
and they said we can't use that one i
said well how about if we use
[ __ ] and they said oh can we
dot out the you and [ __ ] i said
sure
and so there is now a be humble but let
[ __ ]
know t-shirt from the folks at embattled
clothing so if you go to
embattledclothing.com
e-m-b-a-t-t-l-e-d clothing.com
um and uh look for the mark bernardin
universe
of which there are two things it's a
binary star system
well actually that's that's a multiverse
one thing is
two shirts there's a multiverse of shirt
uh so if you go there search for that
and use the code mark 15 you'll get 15
off your first order there's t-shirts
there's hoodies there's
iphone cases there's all kinds of [ __ ]
that has
fancy logos on instagram what is the
origin of the uh
phrase um it's it began
to be sort of like a credo i suppose for
me
um the further i got into into a
professional life
and just how i how i choose to operate
in the world
it's like always be humble always
realize that you're lucky to be here
always realize that nothing is taken for
granted
but never let anybody sleep on you and
then always
remind them that you're actually good at
this that you actually have skills that
you actually bring something to the
table
that they may or may not have forgotten
about so it's that duality
of you know walk softly and carry a big
stick uh
talks often carry a big stick um like
batman beyond kids you love mark bernard
and go buy a shirt where is it where's
the url
embattledclothing.com
and that's like more time with the net
what does this shirt say on it
be humble but let [ __ ] know
so beautiful and i saw if i remember
correctly
i saw you put it up and then you read
somebody was like
here it is and somebody oh and the shirt
is that what happened
in the same thread in which i announced
it five minutes later
somebody had like a tea fury or a
t-sizzle or whatever
account with that saying on it and so i
had to like
[ __ ] write let me go dear teespring
here's what happened i p violation
they're stealing my stuff
which was the weirdest [ __ ] thing
i've never had to do before
and they're crazy welcome to the world
where it's like you know i
you know i said a thing i'm gonna put it
on a shirt and somebody's like that's my
shirt now
i'm the captain of your shirt now
exactly
uh embattled clearly you could go to
define the
mark bernard universe of shirts indeed
of which there are two
that's multiverse um right uh today
ladies and gentlemen christian harloff
great christian harlow uh over on uh
schmodown
uh like uh said uh let me see
today is the wrestlemania
of of shmo down and it's actually
happening right now it started at noon
so my match is at six o'clock
you can watch me in the schmodown um
taking on i don't think i'm at liberty
to say let me see just a heads up we
don't reveal
who it is before the match if you plug
it
do you mind saying um
you are facing do you mind saying you
were
facing if you plug it
do you mind saying you are facing brett
sheridan from
scn live there you go so i'm
gonna be facing brett sheridan from scn
live six o'clock kids
uh you can go watch me schmoe down
the [ __ ] out of it and whatnot will i
win will i defend my title
find out tonight i love that shimoda
mark almost scared me off of it the
first time because he was like they
asked real hard questions like who was
the
in cool world and i was like i i don't
[ __ ] know that's scary
no the first time i did it when i
battled jericho took on jericho um
nothing that hard man so i look forward
to tonight's match
and i had a really good time doing it
but i realized early on
that i was competing against people who
took this very very seriously
and like that they were studying and i'm
like i'm just
swatting in here with what's already in
my brain and
once you hit like who are the bad guys
in cool world
guys i'm sorry i put in a lot of
training with my man coy coy is my
manager we're part of the court i'm part
of team quirky mercs
uh so yeah we are you put in the time if
you want to be a winner
mark i don't know if anyone ever told
you this but like
you want fame well fame costs and here's
where you start
paying and sweat that's what debbie
allen said in fact
i did not have the eye of the tiger it
turns out
like i can't i don't want to disgrace
the league with my half-assedness
oh can i show you something that
somebody sent me for free
um it happens a bunch and i like that
kind of thing so i want to encourage it
so that they keep sending [ __ ] this
big old box
came and it's got this
the mandalorian on inside a big sigil
i posted this on my instagram
as well but this is
the folks who make columbia jackets
they made a mandalorian line and they
sent it look at this
oh that's adorable
you could dress your kid up like baby
yoda and yourself up look at that
my wife took the hoodie already oh [ __ ]
man this is just the wrapping paper bro
it's just paper like tissue paper and
it has mando and the child on it and
then look at this gigantic jacket
it's got multi layers and stuff like
that
it zips down look at it's got and it's
warm weather cold weather gear
if i was going someplace really cold i
would totally wear this but check this
[ __ ] out dude
they just sent this like let me zip it
back up
three three hundred bucks dude they sent
a three hundred dollar
oh if i was going to sundance i'd be
wearing this right now i'll tell you
that much man
uh and look at this it comes with this
man
hold on this
is the way this this is the way mark
it's not badass it's like a hoodie that
looks like [ __ ] mando himself
i appreciate how lucasfilm was like you
know what we're not gonna have a ton of
merch for season one
but we're opening the [ __ ] garage for
season two
oh my good lord they for as little as
they did
before the show came out and i think
everyone will always appreciate the fact
that they did it that way because baby
yoda was a total [ __ ] surprise and
stuff like that
um so for no merch coming out in advance
of mandalorian
they have more than made up for that
like man you can't
i saw somebody got one of them talking
yodas that actually like
blinks and coos and stuff like that
um they got it they got that [ __ ]
everywhere like and
and really really i mean that's high-end
it's one thing if you're like
here's a mando figure columbia making
jackets
like that's nuts so thank you to the
folks of columbia
for sending that coat um i will wear it
in hof like weather
and man oh man while we're on the
subject before we dive into all the news
shall we talk about this week's episode
let's do it uh bill burr
sitting there in the mess hall like
having that conversation that ptsd
conversation like for a
for an episode that didn't have ahsoka
going for it
didn't have the return of boba fett
although boba fett was back with a shiny
new helmet he cleaned up his armor and
stuff like that
yeah very much so for for an episode
that like you know doesn't have those
big moments that just you know we saw in
the previous two episodes
i found this episode oddly compelling
man
like quietly compelling um it's the
second time we get to see
mando take his his helmet off and
and well what's his name what is bill
burr's character mixley or something
like that
oh i can't even remember he yeah like he
gets to see
mando with his helmet off before rogue
how strange is that like all this time
grogu's never seen him with his helmet
off yet this guy
gets to say it um i i even before they
got to that mess hall scene which
honestly
is probably one of the 20 best star wars
scenes
in anything in any star wars anything uh
it's a has a real quentin tarantino
flavor
of tension to it as you're like what's
going to happen before we eventually see
what does
happen um bill burr's performance was
absolutely haunted in that moment he was
fun throughout the episode and whatnot
sounded like dante and randall together
in in some places and his observations
about the empire
but man when it came time to like dance
he gave us some serious chops in that
in that scene uh i and also i just found
like something i'd never seen before
um the imperial celebration i mean i
guess they're not
quite imperials they start talking about
order we're going to bring order which
is like obviously they're on their way
to the first order
but when their transport made it all the
way through
how happy those [ __ ] nazis were
never see that in a star wars thing like
you know in
in the rebels like uh with you know on
hot they're like the first transports
got away and they're all like
yeah and [ __ ] like they're all
celebrating i can't think of a single
thing
where the empire was shown celebrating
you know where they were like
we did it like good for us like you
never see the bad guys
having a good time like the most you
ever see is like grand moff tarkin being
like evacuate in our moment of triumph i
think you underestimate that chances
but this was like literally soldiers
going like [ __ ] a one of the trucks
got through
and like glad
it's it's what happens it's what happens
when the empire gets its ads kicked for
so long
because this is fun remember oh no these
are space nazis crew
had a small victory yeah like when when
because
we're five years post jedi and like all
they needed was a win
just the slightest win like guys we got
one truck
you know we lost two death stars like
two years ago
empires did vader's dead we lost
everybody cool
let's get cake you know we got one truck
in guys it's
miller time yeah like you saw how many
trucks
those skiff guys killed man and one made
it through
like this is nuts now we've got the fuel
to do whatever the [ __ ] we're gonna do
it was just something i'd never seen
before you know
and mandalorian's very good at showing
us things
we've never seen before but they're very
good at showing us the familiar in new
ways
this was a concept that i've never seen
produced jc jump in you think anything
where the empire
like goes woohoo we're winning
uh let's see oh there we go
sorry hitting lots of buttons this week
i haven't seen anything like that uh you
know you got it at the end of return of
the jedi when the
the statues were toppled on coruscant
and stuff
but uh yeah this is definitely uh an
empire that needed us a small win to
feel good about themselves
but i mean just in general like even
tearing down the statues of course
that's the good guys celebrating a big
i cannot think of a single [ __ ] time
in the entire star wars canon
where we saw the empire being like yeah
we did it we're in this together
like i'm getting it
it was so foreign and yet oddly so
welcome because i'm like
yeah they're made up of human beings too
and they're misguided [ __ ] terrible
villainous idiots but you know like any
human being who's like we've
accomplished
they would they would celebrate a goal
it was just so
strange to see and and oddly satisfying
where i was like
never saw that before i'd have to go
back uh to rogue one
and see if the the imperials on scarif
who
won that skirmish until they got blown
up
if there was any like hey hey guys we we
blew up that x-wing
yay but i think that might be the last
time
you rarely see it like it's always
they're always in helmets
and you know [ __ ] generally they
don't cut to like the officer class
being like woohoo or something but this
i got the distinct feeling
of celebration which i was like that is
completely [ __ ] new
in this universe um good for them good
for showing me painting with a color
i've never seen before
uh this episode was written and directed
by um
rick and he's he's the guy who did uh
um the first season we all loved in the
second season we did not
um is this his third no true detective
did he do true detective
um i don't think he did what do i know
the name from
he did a film called dope oh that's
right this was the guy who was going to
do the flash movie
right and he did
he did an episode in season one of
mandalorian also yeah this was his
return did he also do the other bill
burr episode
i think he might have i think he might
have
you see as the resident star wars head
i'm i'm really disappointed in you
not knowing this there's uh as we found
out there's
so much star wars that happens now
that like you no one person like i would
have to be hired by lucasfilm
and put in a room with no windows and an
internet connection and just be like
consume star wars and i still probably
wouldn't know all of it
that's an excellent point man time was
and i'm feeling it too i'm 50 years old
kids and there's a time
where i was like uber star wars fan
number one
and like known for it in my work and
[ __ ] like that
um it's it is virtually impossible to
keep up with all the star wars
there is now uh and it's tough to be
completely
knowledgeable as well um you know
especially as we see
they're collapsing all of these star
wars threads not just the canon but
extended universe
video games bits and pieces of the
cartoons
are all being brought into the universe
and i'm not insanely well schooled
in all of that you know what i'm saying
like just like when it came to star trek
i knew all the star trek movies ah
that's familiar with the star trek tv
shows
um when it came to star wars i was
familiar with everything about the
movies but
the extended universe was outside of my
area of expertise and now it's all
extended universe being brought in
so as much as like i've been around to
see all this [ __ ]
there are some things that like i'm
completely unfamiliar with
which makes it thrilling for me i'm glad
that i don't know as much about star
wars as i used to know
because it allows me to be surprised
every week or like what's this
and also allows me to deep dive where
i'm like wait was that reference that
must mean something and i go looking it
up and stuff like that so
it's engaging me in a way that star wars
hasn't engaged me in decades because i'm
like well i know all that
i know those we have now yeah
i was gonna say we have something now
though that when we were all kids we
didn't have which is
wookiepedia which i can type in
and find out that uh rick did do
the last bill burr episode which was
chapter six the prisoner
right at my fingertips again i can't
express this enough dope is a fantastic
movie
um and if you watch this episode of the
mandalorian
you would and watch dope you would not
be like oh i could see
that person doing that like it's clearly
a leap forward and i say that with the
utmost esteem because i
enjoyed the [ __ ] out of dope um this is
a cat who could paint with
many different colors man i'm a director
who's like you want jay and bob i'll
give you that all day long there's a cat
who's like not only can i give you dope
but i can give you their show as well
which is also my show because he wrote
he wrote on it too
what do you think the story there is man
favreau letting him write on it
you know i don't know maybe maybe some
of it is
you know as we will discuss later favro
seems to be a busy dude
um because there there are 48 new star
wars shows
um of which he's probably overseeing all
of them
so it could just be like hey man you got
a feel for this this is actually his
third episode
he did chapter two the child where we
first actually meet
uh baby yoda slash growbu um
the wait he two episodes last year yeah
he did
uh chapter two in chapter six so it
sounds like
he was there for ground up for the
building of the show as well
yeah i think so you know so if you're
gonna if you're gonna hand anybody the
keys
and say you know go for it it seems like
he's got the most
been there since the go around and it
also could be a thing where the dude was
like hey i got a pitch for a story and
fabre was like oh my god that's great go
write it
yeah i also appreciated um one of my
favorite movies
uh it's an old french film called wages
of fear did you ever see wages of fear
um it's about um this sort of way
station at the end of nowhere it's like
a black and white jimmy jam
um from the 60s um basically like the
french foreign legion like here's where
you go if you have no place else to go
and a bunch of desperate dudes take a
job to drive a truck full of
nitroglycerin
across the jungle um
and uh and and it's it's shaky and it's
volatile and all kinds of things get in
the way and so it becomes this
you know are you are you steely enough
to be able to pull this off will you not
panic under pressure can you do the
impossible
um uh william freaking would then be
make it with roy schneider later as
sorcerer
oh yeah yeah which is also similarly a
great movie but that
the the inherent idea of we have to take
this
explosive thing from point a to point b
and awful [ __ ] is going to happen along
the way if you go too fast if you go too
slow
if anything you know external has a
problem with it um
and so this is like the fourth version
of that story
and i like it every time i see it
um i just uh did the the absolute worst
thing and started looking at
oh dude don't do that i mean fascinating
but the problem is like you want to
answer every question as the
as they happen and stuff kids just know
that we're
we're seeing you we're i'm seeing you in
chat
you're acknowledged um they said they do
hope that we acknowledge dave filoni
more
uh so many don't and he deserves to be
with all uh he contributes are you
kidding me we always [ __ ] blow felony
on this show
we blew him like crazy during the ahsoka
episode of course
and yes dave has been there for the
building of this it seems from the
ground up with
uh with john favreau as well but yeah
when i think of the mandalorian of
course i think of uh
john favreau and i think of john dave
filoni like right there
next to him at this point yeah i think
dave filoni
um i'm i'm as much as impressed with
what
uh favreau has been able to pull off
with this filoni's patience and his
long game is astonishing because like
hey
i took this job you know george wanted
to meet me because i did a bunch of
avatar the last airbenders and he liked
my style and
said you want to do this clone wars show
sure and then he turned it into
the best version of star wars in a lot
of ways and
then gets to work on the mandalorian and
then gets to bring in his
grand creation from clone wars ahsoka
tano into live action
and i bet you he's a guy who runs the
ahsoka show because if not i don't know
what's happening
um it is it's a incredibly well laid
plan
if it was such and if not he's managed
to play every
every every hand that's been dealt him
incredibly well
uh there's a lot of love for saucer your
reference to saucer
um and when i say a lot of love um i
mean it was uh
it was it was one person over and over
but it was adorable
uh bat bluth was just like saucer or
more sorcerer talk
i you can watch that on me and mark
spin-off on sunday nights
uh cast on that roy scheider classic
200 episodes on sorcerer um
yeah man it was a it was a really great
episode and going into it i was like
all right well you know it ain't gonna
be ahsoka
uh and it's not going to be the return
of boba fett
maybe this is a quieter episode or
something like that
and i i thought it was j and you know uh
just as compelling i thought they had
some cool [ __ ] i'd never seen in in a
star wars before
and familiar things where i'm like oh
yeah this is comfort comfortable as well
um we have one more episode is that
right
i think so so that means
do we think we're going to see a jedi
rogue sitting on that rock uh you know
sending that cerebral code out into the
world and whatnot
do we think that we're gonna see uh jedi
show up in this
last episode of the last season and i by
the way i think i just read something
says that there's speculation
season three returns december
2021 could be
yeah i think i think they actually said
that on um on the disney investor call
we're a year away from [ __ ] season
three at this point
yeah which is so weird because it felt
like there was a smaller gap between
season one and season two but i guess
not
right it was like a nine month gap you
know
it was like we wrapped in december
of 2019 i think and then we got it back
in october
so it finished right after rise of
skywalker
right before i think before yeah
right um you know i don't know if we go
so far i mean i
it's a thing that i thought we were
gonna get um end the season with
our first jedi sighting um
but it seems very quick for that
dustin's side says i hope
and bet it's ezra um
do we see uh is there a lot of uh
support for the idea of ezra i see a lot
of calcus as well
my money's on ezra if i had to if i had
to put a
bet down on the roulette wheel of jedi
it would be on ezra
um then this would be the first live
action to ezra ever correct
yeah um with the uh you know what i mean
i was just about to start talking uh
ahsoka but we might as well dive into
the news for that shall we
we should my friend we should uh mark
bernardin
is an old hand of the news before he was
a fancy dan with his own
work office as a writer affection
uh mark bernardin covered facts ladies
and gentlemen
he invented facts in this entertainment
news game he's a news man he brought us
some news mark
tell us what is the news well
you know it's funny this week was going
to be you know
mostly about spider-man multiverse [ __ ]
it's like and that's still pretty huge
and you know the words yeah disney's
having an investor call which they do
every year
you know maybe even every quarter for
that matter and just tell people who are
investing and buying disney stock
what they're actually buying like what
do we got going on you guys i know you
want me you want to hear about you know
technology and
we understand that the theme parks are
down and the cruises are down and we
understand
how does one get on those calls like do
you have to own disney stock do you have
to own a certain percentage of disney
stock
um i i have to imagine it's a certain
percentage of disney stock because i
have like
one share of disney and they didn't i
gotta share too and nobody's
ever invited me to this phone call i'm
always reading about it online
yeah i mean there there is a link like
anybody can watch the investor call
um they do sort of black out the more
sensitive clips so it becomes like hey
so here's our new shiny show from
davidie kelly and then there's just the
title card is up for 90 seconds while
they show the people who've invested
millions
what they're getting from david e kelly
um but i was able to watch alone so the
investors get to see
some [ __ ] that the public don't correct
that makes sense
yeah uh i suppose um but i
i was able to get that link and so i
could watch what they were willing to
show the general public
and it's it is a a fanfare parade
of executives kind of like hi my name is
kathy kennedy
let me tell you about all the [ __ ] we
haven't going on with star wars and
let's put up a title card for this and
let's
throw two footage from the bad batch and
let's
and you know over and over and over
again and then it's hey let's see what's
happening over at fx and then here's you
know
land graph will come out and say well
here's what we got coming up and it's
this just
this dog and pony show in a very real
way i don't like the
up fronts it is it is you know
it's up front for people who are
spending millions slash hundreds of
millions of dollars to keep disney
afloat
and so they brought every big gun they
had and
you know in a week in which we were kind
of talking about the fallout from hbo
max
kind of releasing their 2021 slate
directly onto the streaming service but
what could possibly you know sort of
overwhelm that in our mind's eye and
then disney
was like look at my giant throbbing
lightsaber
and they've been so quiet on the star
wars and uh
marvel front all year this is 2020 is
the first year with no marvel film
thanks to
kovid coming out of the box office so
you know most of the announcements we
received
marvel wise this year were like this is
delayed this is delayed
delayed and then suddenly with this
phone call they also
unfurled a lot of marvel information but
uh let's start with the star wars
because
good lord that's they turned disney plus
into star wars central and i'm here for
it
uh so they announced a whole [ __ ] ton of
tv shows or at the very least gave more
information
on the ones we already knew about the
rogue one prequel
um you know following cassio and endor
is called star wars endor
so we're going to get you know more kind
of
rebellious spy [ __ ] by the sound of it
uh alan uh two dicks uh robot right k2
so or whatever
is coming back um you know
gabriel no not gabriella is it gabriel
in there
i can't remember this [ __ ] there was too
much [ __ ] news
okay cassie and andor coming back yeah
so diego luna playing cassian andor
um you know it's it's going to be
one of their giant shining you know
[ __ ] tv shows it is not
tying into the mandalorian which is now
the flagship
they have two other shows for that two
whole other shows of the six they
announced
are going to tie directly into the
mandalorian ahsoka
star wars colon ahsoka absolute
no-brainer
it felt like the episode they showed us
was a you know backdoor pilot you know
she
said her intent her mission uh we saw
her in action
uh it seemed like it was set up for a
spin-off
and then you know less than two weeks
later they said guess what it is by the
way
uh in addition to that we're getting
star wars rangers of the new republic
this is from patty jenkins no
patty jenkins is doing star wars rogue
squadron as a feature film
so this is not the same thing nope what
is this
nobody really knows there's not a ton of
information about star wars uh
range of the new republic this car what
cara dune is she a ranger of the new
republic as
one of those i mean she was a drop
trooper
um but maybe she becomes part of the
range of the new republic
and the new republic is like now
like not now but post return of the jedi
correct
yeah it's set within the timeline of the
mandalorian um
and it's coming from favro and dave
filoni and it will
like ahsoka tie in to the mandalorian
and all three of these shows
are going to culminate in some climactic
event series
much like the defenders did with the
marvel netflix shows
like a a world uh world threatening an
avengers level threat that brings all
the shows together
right you know probably palpatine if i
know my star wars
again this [ __ ] won't die
um it is uh so let me see honchofat says
cara dune
is now a republic marshall on navarro so
would that
count is that i don't know if that's a
ranger but we don't know
very much of anything about it i'm i'm
getting the terms confused all right so
somebody who is somebody just put it
ponchofat says textus rangers first i'm
getting a lot of information from honcho
fete today
honcho fett says it's texas rangers for
star wars if that's what it is
i'm [ __ ] in if it's like remember in
the episode on the ice planet where the
the
two x-wing dudes showed up and they were
like hey man [ __ ]
take it easy and then took off i'm all
for that man if it's like
chips in space i'm all for that man
that's awesome
if i had to guess judging by information
we have which might not be all there is
grand admiral thrawn will probably be
the big bad
um that these three shows will
eventually intertwine to deal with
that's like it he's going to be there
thanos yes i like it
um you know andorra as we said before
diego luna
uh it's created by tony gilroy you know
oscar winner tony gilroy who did
all that wait what who who tony gilroy
is doing
what which show is he creating andor
he's doing it because he worked on rogue
one right so he was part of the the crew
that introduced cassian andor so he's
picking up the reins
and moving forward and stella skarsgard
is in that fiona shaw
denise gough and jen genevieve o'reilly
is mon mothma
oh right on let's get some mothma action
[ __ ] yes um obi wan kenobi
is for real coming um which
you know has been kind of on the on the
burners for a bit
um and hayden christensen is returning
as anakin skywalker slash darth vader
now is he when so at this point in the
show they're saying this is post
uh a few years after revenge of the sith
so this is not happening during
obviously the clone wars have already
happened so this is
when he goes to tatooine to you know
become a recluse and look after
baby luke from a distance so that means
that hayden christensen is literally
going to be playing darth vader
you know uh what all that the press
had said was that he's returning as uh
evil sith lord darth vader
whether or not it's he's got to be in
the suit at that point he's got to be in
the suit
um unless there's flashbacks unless
there's
you know you get the kind of tony stark
helmet cam
of of actual anakin skywalker inside the
suit
um i've never thought about that let me
try to process that idea real quick hold
on
moist do we really want to see a hacked
up hayden christensen
like to jarvis i don't i don't know but
i've never thought about that before
yeah man i'm curious what they're gonna
do with them if he's just gonna be the
guy inside the suit is it going to be
james earl jones doing his voice if he's
playing darth vader
a lot of questions there but happy to
see hayden christensen come back
a lot of questions the entire series
will be directed by
deborah chao who also shot some of
uh mandalorian season one um
what else do we got we get the bad batch
for a while right that's a cartoon
that's a cartoon you know also
kind of from the mind of dave filoni um
uh we saw first footage of it during the
investor call and the clips they showed
look pretty sweet
um we're getting a [ __ ] lando
calrissian show
which i feel like we kind of knew about
but then didn't see any confirmation
anywhere besides this
um justin simeone who made dear white
people the movie dear white people the
tv show
and bad hair for hulu is is developing
this currently
for disney plus um there's an anime
anthology project called star wars
visions
um and lando calrissian of course is is
gonna be
uh donald glover naturally it's unclear
they haven't announced any casting it's
an event series so it's not an ongoing
so it's just going to be eight episodes
you know knock on wood fingers crossed
they get donald glover back
i love star wars man where they're like
hey we're gonna tell this story for like
10 episodes and then we're done like
this is all we need
and never mind all this like it's a
movie so everyone back the [ __ ] up the
whole world's got to stop like
they're like look here's another show
here's another show and they're event
shows but like you're going to be able
to watch them at home and
the adventure is going to continue every
week and they're all going to tie in
together i'm
i like star wars like this new
incarnation star wars i see a bunch of
people
in um in which mccall
um the chat who were talking about how
much star wars is too much star wars i
mean number one i guess we're about to
see
but everything they've announced so far
i don't
there's nothing i'm kicking that nothing
where i'm like we don't need that
we're that stupid like that sounds all
of it so far sounds pretty damn viable
what else they got i i was going to say
and some people are echoing in the chat
how awesome would it be to do like a jim
henson storyteller
with billy dee telling
stories of his youth where you have
donald glover
acting out kind of the whole show in
flashback
this is the money i've put aside for
your very show
i want to do your show right now
that would be cool man because then you
get billy d every episode
it's like young indiana jones except
you'd really have
the guy every episode instead of a guy
playing the guy
that's a good idea um do me a favor call
kathy kennedy and tell her that what'd
you jc
let me tell you about the time i caught
space herpes
um what other star wars they given us i
hear there's a droid show a cartoon with
r2d2 and c3po
a droid story yeah by the time they
remember those [ __ ] man they
they just kicked this universe open
forever stakes the original
cutesy wootzies the original baby yodas
if you will
uh r2d2 and c3po it's nice that they're
getting animated series
yeah well it's actually it's a movie
it's a it's an adventure film for disney
plus
droid story uh will introduce us to a
new droid hero
guided by r2 and c3po
so another human like a luke skywalker
and they go on with them yeah or maybe
another droid
maybe it's a like you know bb-8 or k2so
or
ig whatever like give us a new awesome
cool droid
and have two oldie droids so like this
is how you do it kid
i like it man and the acolyte
which uh leslie hedland who did russian
doll this had been announced before that
she was doing the show but we didn't
know a what it was called or b
that it was uh going to a mystery
thriller that will take viewers into a
galaxy of shadowy secrets
and emerging dark side powers in the
final days of the high republic
era so that is not in the mandalorian
timeline it's not in the
sort of battle of yavin timeline it is
way before that if i'm correct on that
jc
star and it's death oriented it's about
evil people
i think it's about the rise of the sith
if i had to guess
wow high republic is kind of their new
multimedia campaign that they launched
with uh starting with like novels and
comic books and
things like that so i'm assuming that
this show will tie into kind of the
the roots that are getting laid right
now with um
with novels and and all the kind of
expanded media
so would that mean that uh not of course
grogu
or baby yoda but would a young yoda be
in this
i believe young yoda is in it i think
it's like he's 300 years old
in it i believe is what i read strapping
young yoda yoda with
dirt open and [ __ ] sex change yoda
yoda's in high republic i don't know
that he's in the tv
show but he is in uh in that world of
media i think like
who for those you know for for people
who are like hey man like that's too far
back you know how they're doing this uh
game of thrones prequel and it's like
ooh are any of the characters from game
of thrones in it they're like no
not at all these these are events that
happen hundreds of years before
um will there be i hope
characters that you know can
thread us through like it'd be nice to
see a young yoda show up in that show if
it makes sense in the timeline well i
think you'll get
you know one of the most popular video
games is knights of the old republic
so i think what you're going to do is
tap into a lot of
uh nostalgia for people who've played
that video game for 15 years
nice see that's something i never did so
i i'll be it'll all be new to me
it's all new to you um two other star
wars things we talked about the
anthology
star wars visions where it's going to be
i think 10 episodes of
um made by anime filmmakers all from
japan um all different all-new
all kind of through a different cultural
lens which is
super exciting matrix did that a while
back
the animatrix was like yeah just [ __ ]
playing this ip however you want
guys who make anime and it was it was
pretty interesting
um we're getting two movies we knew
about one we knew that tech away tv was
making
i said announcement that was they just
said hey he's making a movie
he's making a movie they showed a logo
which looked like monty python's life of
brian
it was like this weird animated kind of
crumbly stoney logo
um so it's unclear if it's an animated
movie it's unclear
you know what it is beyond its tiger so
it's probably going to be a little funny
do we know what its title is nope well
yeah still mysterious um but the other
the surprise was patty jenkins um
rogue squadron um you know she
she released this little kind of mini
movie clip thing on
on twitter which was just her kind of
like rollerblading up to her car
and like hey man you know my dad was a
fighter pilot and
and i've always loved i've always wanted
to make a movie set you know
dealing with this kind of heroism and
guys up in space and i love speed and
i've always i've been trying to find the
right project to do this and she gets
into her car
and like takes off you know you can't
see it it's all below camera but she
like takes over roller blades
but then she picks up so finally i found
the right you know the right way to tell
the story the right meeting with the
right people and she puts on
uh an x-wing you know helmet and then
she turns and she
lifts up the orange jumpsuit and walks
over
to the tarmac on which an x-wing is
sitting and she's like
i found the thing that lets me do
everything that i love star wars rogue
squadron
is uh is coming soon so that's [ __ ]
awesome
uh the grave that's awesome for her
she's such a cool lady very talented and
stuff what
we don't know what it's about though um
i mean rogue squadron
um has been in the lord it's been in
video games for a while and there have
been comics about rogue squadron they
are
you know even beyond red squadron the
most famous
gathering of pilots in star wars um no
idea what the
narrative is going to be but yeah those
are not that is not a call sign without
some level of
legacy to it is that indeed all the star
wars they told us about
that i believe it's all the star wars
they told us about i didn't miss
anything did i jason
you forgot to ask me what i'd like to do
so i'd like to pitch right here if i
could mark
the investor phone call um i
uh you know i s in a world where we're
doing all the star wars we can and i
fully support this um i think
perkins a limited series
in my hands would be a story worth
telling you know it tells the story of
his life
in the star wars universe right up to of
course
his heroic moment on the death star
battle of the death star star wars
smith's perkins
colon a star wars anecdote
i bet you're not going to do that
i'm all in like there's not a single
announcement they made about star wars
that i was like
too much i'm like keep it coming keep it
coming
and good for these cats i'll never
forget when they announced disney's
buying star wars i was like
wow why it's over it's dead like [ __ ]
it's
it's done why would you it's you're just
owning the video rights like that's how
lack of uh that's what a lack of
visionary i am
that i couldn't see that you could
simply tell new stories expand the
universe remember years ago
when there were rumors like george lucas
is gonna make a star wars tv show
like we live in that rumored reality now
where they're making not just one not
just two but like three or [ __ ] four
star wars tv shows that each sound as
good as the [ __ ] last man so
boy star wars is back and truly
perfected at this point man keep all
those people
in charge they seem to be doing the
right thing and it smells like because
of covid
we're getting a lot more star wars than
we were probably gonna get
a year ago does that seem like the case
to you you know
maybe maybe i mean covet still you know
brings its own production
realities and its own nightmares but the
thing that i'm excited about
is that i remember when you know we were
talking about force awakens and talking
about you know rise of skywalker last
jedi
and it always felt that star wars was a
nostalgia driven enterprise
right but it was banking especially you
know the both the prequels and now the
the post sequels that it was all about
our love for this thing that we hadn't
gotten a lot of
and it seems like they've done a lot of
work to just earn our eyes without
nostalgia
um you know finding ways to give it to
us when they can and in new and
interesting ways
you know like boba fett him being
anywhere is pure nostalgia you know and
pure fan service
um you know lando feels a bit like that
as well but that's fine
because in event series and if you give
me donald glover freight episodes or
billy d for you know bookending it
awesome
but a lot of these shows or with
characters i've never heard of
you know when never interacting or
intersecting with the skywalker saga
and it's just new stories in a world
that i love so i'm here for it
can i uh billy reynolds in the chat just
made me laugh because he's
he's still pitching on my perkins
project
and he says perkins pulling out a shower
pipe in the rogue squadron shower
cubicles
to see through to the ladies dude so
it's porkins and porkys and [ __ ]
you said he puts his lightsaber right
through the hole man
billy reynolds i salute you that was
hysterical um all right
um somebody said start don't kid
yourself star wars is dead but i gotta
tell you
i i i feel it quite the opposite right
now
star wars feels here it is bland says
don't fool yourself star wars is dead
i don't know bland they just announced
like 96 new star wars things so
if it did they [ __ ] reanimated that
corpse man
but i don't think it's dead i think it
may be alive for the first time in a
long time
indeed so on to marvel
yes yes and i know there's a bunch but i
just want to lead with this did you see
that [ __ ] what if trailer
yes jesus christ that animation looks
amazing
like amazing it looks like spider-verse
animation
yes oh it looks expensive that's what it
looks like
that animation that you got to pay a lot
for and it makes sense because it's
disney the house of animation they
practically invented this [ __ ]
so i was delighted when i saw that uh
trailer i
you know i was always up for like what
if that's a good idea but
it is stunning stunning
the [ __ ] animation they're dealing
with in that show i can't wait that
jumped like right to the top of my list
where i was like oh and then hearing
oatu hearing what's jeff what's his name
oh my god so [ __ ] good so yeah i saw
i saw that trail i saw all the trailers
but that was
absolutely my favorite the one that
surprised me the most
because like i see stills of you know uh
captain britain
of peggy carter getting the super
soldier serum but seeing all that [ __ ]
in motion
was kind of awesome seeing zombie
[ __ ] caps seeing
um did they who was it was it um
t'challa as um yeah taken by
uh by the guardians by the guardians so
he's star-lord
um all of that stuff like yeah [ __ ] it
give it all to me
sorry um yeah and and michael um
mike rooker's doing his own voice
everyone's doing their own voices some
of the animation
looks like you know uh
what's that [ __ ] called like rotoscope
where they're actually shooting people
and then animating over their faces yeah
i mean
the animation looks sick i mean it's all
cg but there's
there's some like hand tuning to it
there's some
yeah it's it's some weird [ __ ]
all right so give us the list what is
kevin feige the great
kevin feig the only kevin that [ __ ]
matters in this universe
what did he announce uh well let's talk
about
the tv stuff um they announced secret
invasion
um starring uh nick fury and talos
spinning out of captain marvel what is
the do we know the premises
um i mean secret invasion was a was a
mini-series that marvel had put out you
know years ago written by
brian uh michael bendis um which is
about you know
shape-shifters who had been long in
place on earth
who had done like you know awful it's
like a hydra story basically
or what if half of the people you
thought you knew turned out to be
um skrulls um
and so to to do that with getting
[ __ ] sam jackson
and ben mendelsohn to come back as as
nick fury and talos
to root out you know in some kind of
global spy initiative
kind of thing all of the skrulls who've
been deep in hiding on earth
that's kind of badass do you think uh
they turn scrolls bad again or is it
they're gonna keep scrolls as uh
somewhat good whereas the cree
turned out to be the bad people um i
mean i think it
it doesn't hurt them to have a new sort
of alien threat
um and so if you keep talos and his
family as your good scrolls
and then everybody else is a bad one
you know you get the you get a nice
dynamic between talos and nick fury
and everybody else and maybe you get a
super scroll as well
that could be badass not gonna be badass
um they announced
iron heart so riri coming
re-re coming river williams will be here
dominique thorne
is playing remy williams um don't know
anything about it beyond
that again they were they were very very
very kind of
slight on details those unfamiliar with
the concept
uh riri is a girl unrelated to tony
stark who builds her own
iron suit is that correct indeed she
builds the most advanced suit of armor
since iron man
and so in a in a post-iron man world
a mentor is there any contact between
the two and
that's you i think there had been in the
series um
but i don't know if there can be in this
version unless we're setting it
in the past a little bit you know at
least the beginning of it in the past
where it's like oh yeah i got the
i got the tony stark mit scholarship too
peter parker
or it'd be amazing if tony was the uh
was
jarvis in the suit and you get robert
downey jr back
just doing voice work but still i
[ __ ] take it i mean i listen to that
dude [ __ ] tell me i was gonna die
he's so talented
i'm looking forward to that show did
they they also showed a little piece of
miss marvel didn't they
um they showed a little sort of like
behind the scenes clippy thing like
interview with the actress that they got
to play miss marvel um you know and some
of the the filmmakers behind it but they
haven't shot anything yet
um but you know she looks the the young
actor
does what's your name iman vilani
um looks so [ __ ] enthusiastic to be
ms marvel
that uh that i just can't [ __ ] wait
uh linkovich
chamowski in the chat said ironheart
the comic that was canceled several
times you're absolutely right however
guardians of the galaxy was also a very
unsuccessful comic book which
as we all know turned into something
else so just because a book was canceled
number of times doesn't mean
concept's not viable man uh particularly
in live action
formal some things on a page just don't
sing as much as they will
uh in a live-action show so you know
even though it
didn't do well as a comic book i i could
still see this
working as a series man this is wish
fulfillment
like you know we all look at tony stark
and be like oh i wish i could [ __ ] be
that dude
this is a story about a kid who's like
i'm gonna be tony stark it builds a
[ __ ] suit so
yeah i see this totally work and even if
the comic
you know got cancelled once or twice and
let's be fair everything gets cancelled
in comics
uh even if it gets you know renumbered
or something like that
like comics are all about turnover at
this point and stuff
i look forward to this man i think i
think that
ironheart's gonna be a good show i don't
know it's gonna be really good
um orly says the chance to be and you
know to your point
all it needed to do was be one person's
favorite comic um
and it turns out that one of those
people was kevin feige
who was like yes let's do that
um in the same similar armor vein we're
getting
armor wars um based on the classic
marvel series
um says feige said secret invasion will
be as
big of a crossover as civil war
[Music]
do they get everybody back do they spend
all that money
i mean they're spending the money like
that's that there's
that there's no two ways about it man
what are the armor wars
um it's basically what happens um when
uh when james rhodes uh a.k.a
aka war machine uh needs to face what
happens when tony stark's tech falls
into the wrong hands
so that's every [ __ ] marvel anything
isn't that
that's not always what happens but wait
a second if we're doing armor wars
is there a chance that we get uh justin
hammer back
maybe sam rockwell i'll
i'll take four more helpings of sam
rockwell it's been a minute he's one of
the best marvel villains ever was man
don't believe that but i thought he was
captivating as [ __ ]
so it'd be great to see him [ __ ] come
back you know and it also doesn't
surprise me that you'd announce
iron heart and armor wars together
that's a cross overweight nap you ain't
kidding man you ain't kidding that
smells good
um oh baby groot baby groot
what uh what what it's a i am groot
features everyone's favorite baby tree
in a series of just original shorts
more of that guardians of the galaxy
holiday special
[Music]
that's [ __ ] a good idea oh my god
yes james gunn's gonna do it yep right
written and directed by him
what a [ __ ] awesome world we live in
man
um so that's that is the new [ __ ] they
announced um the old [ __ ] which we kind
of knew about but got more information
um falcon in the winter soldier is
coming in march 2021 followed by loki
in may and what if we have do we have a
graphic to put up so i can grab a quick
smoke
where's your yoda i know he's over there
i dare not [ __ ] get up i don't want
to miss
any of this information put up your uh
your columbia
mando box all right kev i i blocked your
video
okay thank you go on mark give mark full
speed is that possible or no
uh i can i'll work on it all right
go ahead mark what else we got uh cs one
division on the 15th
which we knew that falcon winner's new
trailer did you watch the new trailer i
did watch the new trailer
isn't it creepy doesn't it doesn't it
just seem like the [ __ ] show you
can't wait to watch like
it it seems like it's going to be sad
and unsettling as well
it feels like a black mirror episode yes
you know this like weirdness of what
happens when you have so much power and
you're wrecked with grief
and so you decide to remake the world in
a way that you think is going to make
you happy
but it keeps on [ __ ] poking at you
from the outside
um yeah it just it looks like all those
things i can't wait
um did you see that uh they did uh they
talked about
ant-man and the wasp and then they
referenced that
they're recasting cassie with katherine
newton the girl who's in freaky right
now
um gonna be playing his grown-up
daughter
even though there was a different
actress who played her an end game
well the actress who played her and end
game was i think like you know
14 15 years old i think it was like
teenage cassie
um who had all of two lines
and it seems as if you know maybe
they're leaning harder on cassie for
this one so they're casting somebody a
little bit older
um somebody with a little more
experience uh you can bring me back jc
um a lot of people ask you like how come
we can't see kev smoking
on youtube they don't give a [ __ ] but on
uh facebook they make us think about it
so we can keep them off camera because
as mark poured it out before the show
you know rampant racism is fine on
facebook
smoking weed well that might convince
somebody to try it
so that's why we don't um
they also announced something where
a couple weeks ago we were like hey
or a couple months ago we were like
tatyana mislani is going to be in
she-hulk
and then she was like i didn't say that
and the world was like oh i guess she's
not in shield
but they have officially announced that
she is in tatiana mizlani is in sheol
correct
correct you know marvel marvel you know
is very
uh it's always interesting when you know
the press sniffs out a thing
and they report it marvel will just not
comment
they won't say no but they won't confirm
until it's on their own time and so this
was their own time
and so she is indeed playing the lead
role in she-hulk
mark ruffalo and tim roth are back as
this is what i love about what marvel's
doing
with disney plus man like with movies
they're so big and they got to move on
and they're always moving forward and
[ __ ] and building the future
but with the tv shows it seems like now
they're going like let's go back and
catch everybody we've
missed along the way like tim roth as
the abomination was
marvel studios marvel cinematic universe
and stuff
um to be bringing him back man that
feels like a [ __ ] comic book
you know what i'm saying like in comics
they
meet some a bad guy or bad or a villain
uh they defeat the villain
they fight other villains and then a
couple months later that [ __ ] villain
comes back
so it's been years since we saw tim roth
as the abomination but like
him coming back is a tremendous thing
which means we may also get to see the
leader
as well remember like all the [ __ ] they
can't do in a hulk movie because they
don't have the rights to do the hulk
movie
they can now do in this she-hulk series
man so
what was that actor's name who was in
hope blake nelson
yes so there's a chance that tim blake
nelson could come back and be the leader
as well
this excites me no end man it's all
happening
um so yeah so we've got one division
falcon in the winter soldier
um which the new clip looked awesome
did you did you see the new trailer it
looked great
so happy um for which one
talking and winter soldier
i did see i saw all the i saw all the
trailers unfortunately my internet
connection was being unstable again i
saw the trailers
i love the wanda vision one um
i i enjoyed the other two
um uh but there you know the falcon and
the
winter soldier there was a i liked all
the flying stuff
they didn't give me a lot to go on on
that in that trailer
yeah although it felt like for a minute
in the beginning
when uh falcon was going like that
shield has a complicated pass
for a second i was like i wonder if
they're going to touch on remember that
series they did
about the original captain america it
was
pal baker i think did the art on it yes
um
captain america truth yes and it was the
story of
before they tested the super soldier
serum on
steve rogers they tested it on a black
soldier
isaiah bradley do you think they're
bringing that in like that's for some
reason that's what popped in my head
when he said that shield has a
complicated
legacy or whatever i was like oh my god
because that was like one of my favorite
stories they ever did in comics
so they recast carl lumley as
a person who may or may not be isaiah
bradley
really yeah and so i think i think
part of this six episode series is going
to be
perhaps you can't have steve rogers
discover
the truth of uh of what this means
because you know they're not gonna bring
chris evans back house of rio says in
the chat
confirmed isaiah bradley is in the show
yeah
so you know i i think it's maybe even
more meaningful if sam wilson discovers
that this is the origin of the super
social serum this is how this is where
the shield came from this is
this is the beginning of this story that
it had so much
um reverence to him uh let's talk about
the
uh well we'll talk about the loki uh
trailer
but they didn't announce anything oscar
isaac as uh
moon knight did they um i don't think
they
did i mean they announced moon knight
clearly um but
they don't mention his name they did
talk about moon knight though in the
announcement
yeah it was part of their you know
cavalcade of [ __ ] coming
his deal is not quite done then he must
not be
you know and he also seems to mention
stuff that we also knew about
like uh although would they the ant-man
and the wasp has a title now
quantum mania did confirm that
kang is gonna be in it um
uh and something else was confirmed
where i was oh i guess it was the
katherine newton plane
cassie thing right let's go to loki
um what is now are you familiar with the
what is it the vm or uva whatever the
tva what the thing he was just like
yeah the weird agency that seems to be
tracking him
not at all um but the idea that there is
some
temporal copy unit that understands that
loki is somehow bouncing through time
eliot thomas in chat says mephisto is in
the loki trailer did you see that i
didn't see that
i didn't see that either that would
all right so sith guy says tva is time
variance authority
okay that's from the books right like
that's in the
timeline variance authority so i guess
they're like the time cops and
uh rick and morty who are like stop
[ __ ] with time
um the uh i'm telling you man the
what's his name uh um
wilson cohen yeah and gray hair looked
good
wow happy to see him i was like oh i
like him like i forgot how much i liked
him it's like
are you traveling through time again wow
i wanted uh i'm look i'm all on board
but uh it
i did i don't know what the story is i
was hoping for a little more clarity in
their trailer
but it looks expensive looks like
they're spending all the [ __ ] money
yeah shows all the trailers all the
trailers for all their
series look features they look like
[ __ ] feature films that are repeated
like you know multiple episodes of the
feature film
so we're going to get quality i just i
want a little more on the plot i want to
know a little more on the details man
and if that's true
yeah i saw somebody just wrote in the
that bluth says
loki is d.b cooper did you see that's
what i
thought like in that one shot of him
jumping out of the plane
with the bag i was like so wait is this
like quantum leap
where he's like going to jump into
famous moments in time i thought maybe
it was famous moments in the marvel
universe but
maybe he's just jumping through history
and time i don't know but i'm intrigued
i'm in 100
100 percent so we'll see that in may
braden goss
said that loki is both the hero and the
villain of this show
and boston's same same as sheamus said
rick and morty writers are on loki is
that true
um i don't know
i hope so man um all right
uh what else we got uh talked about ms
marvel
um hawkeye which we know will be coming
in late 2021.
did they confirm like what we've already
seen on the internet with haley
stanfield or whatever yeah i don't think
they were going to hide that you know
we've all seen those pictures of you
know kate bishop
and uh pizza dog um
they also confirmed um vera farmiga tony
dalton
brian darcy james they're not who
they're playing though right
no they did confirm christian bale as
gore the god killer
or god butcher in uh rather in um
loving thunder thunder i mean we all
knew he was in it we all knew that he
was playing a villain and
a lot of people suspected it was it was
gore but apparently they
made that clear and then they did um
yeah
on the movie side um the the biggest
surprise
was fantastic four um
huge and i i when they said that it's
the
boy who's doing spider-man john watts i
said [ __ ]
that is fantastic he's a great director
man them spider-man movies but
nothing but [ __ ] fun and warmth and
that's what the fantastic four
needs to be if if they're the same tone
and flavor
and feel of those spider-man movies
they'll have massive hits on their hands
like that i can't wait
i i you know marvel's first family
uh didn't get to kick open the doors of
the marvel cinematic universe because
fox had the
rights for so long and then you know
it's been ever
forever since coveted came but forget
one year ago
is when disney was like we're buying all
[ __ ] fox so we're getting all of our
toys back
and there's been so much going on and
they had so many other things
in the hopper already to have them
announce that like yes
fantastic four is on its way so much so
that they gave us a [ __ ]
logo and told us who's directing it
uh that's a great day for the marvel
cinematic universe marvel studios
um i i love his spiderman movies the
only thing that could have made me
happier
and it was never going to happen was for
brad bird
to to be the guy they tapped to make a
fantastic four movie but he already made
two of them done it twice
he's already done nice yeah i i think
watts is such a great choice i had no
idea they just announced that right like
that
like that that i was obviously i'm on
board for everything they [ __ ] do but
i was like
that's a stroke of brilliance man just
when spider-man's winding down and stuff
and plus i mean look spider-man's part
of the marvel
studios world as well marvel cinematic
universe but he's primarily
a sony feature so that means john watts
has been a
you know sony working for sony all this
time nice that he's going to come over
and
you know work at disney uh for the next
probably the next trilogy right there's
no way he makes one and walks away he's
probably
gonna do three you know which which also
leads me to believe
that this next spider-man movie might be
the last
spider-man movie for a while because if
john watts isn't gonna make it tom
holland i'm sure they signed him to like
a nine picture deal
but he will already be in you know two
avengers movies
spider-man civil war you know dr strange
will be in there as well so like at some
point
maybe tom holland just becomes a
supporting character in this other
larger universe
leaving john watts to go off and make
threes fantastic four movies
um we also they announced this week um
i think it's official that daredevil uh
um
is going to show up and not just any
daredevil but
our netflix charlie cox daredevil is
actually going to show up in spider-man
3.
um i think it's still a rumor marvel
hasn't confirmed it
um but you know it is a very popular
rumor
and given the fact that the the two-year
clause netflix made
marvel sign and all the actors sign do
not appear in any marvel
uh projects um post their cancellation
from netflix
has now expired um somebody just said it
in a chat and i was going to try to
like just segue into it as my own idea
but credit where credits do
christina bees just said uh miles
morales spider-man
it's absolutely true so when they're
done with tom holland
spider-man as we know it might stop
for a minute but it sounds like or feels
like
maybe that's when they move miles in and
start doing that version
of spider-man that would be an opportune
time and a half right
i mean if you're doing a multiverse
story anyway
and you're inviting every other [ __ ]
peter parker in it anyway
then you know there's a world in which
you can 100
also invite miles morales into
spider-man 3.
um ask that kid remember the kid on the
internet who was doing all those flips
and [ __ ]
and he played a couple different
characters but he really looked just
like him and stuff
um so yeah i mean they haven't confirmed
miles morales
i i bet you that you know sony is
currently like
guys you're doing all the things that we
did already
but like with more money and you're
getting
the real like because i'm sure for enter
the spider-verse they wanted to get toby
and andrew to come back and voice
their versions of the characters but
couldn't um and i was like but they're
they're doing it
they're taking all of our stuff
what a what a great time to be alive
like [ __ ] in this dopey investor call
they just gave us 25 good reasons to
stay alive for the next [ __ ] 10 years
indeed um in more marvel movie stuff we
talked about quantomania
ms marvel and monica rambo will appear
in captain marvel 2.
in the trailer the new wand division
trailer now this is monica
is um the daughter of
uh captain marvel's friend from
from uh the captain marvel movie yeah
maria rambo
with that little girl who she like gave
the jacket to and stuff
so that's grown up and in the one
division trailer she's indicating she
doesn't even know
like wanda doesn't know her and she
doesn't even know why she's there and
stuff but she becomes
captain marvel doesn't she in the in the
comics at one point
um yes yes so that means
did they also say that ms marvel is
going to be in captain marvel 2.
there's so many marvels as all the
marvels with the exception of shazam
himself
[Laughter]
um feige said addressing the biggest
question about black panther 2
that they will not be recasting t'challa
um out of respect for the late chadwick
boseman
um how do you feel about this i think
it's a
beautiful gesture but i saw a lot of
people online
making the argument for like look we all
love chadwick but like that character
t'challa is bigger than one actor and
you know that character meant the world
to me and and
to you know to have them just say like
okay well
that version of black panther is now not
going to be
uh engaged anymore because chadwick
passed away
some folks were feeling like well wait a
second that's my hero
like you know can't they keep going and
a lot of people understand that of
course there's going to be another
black panther and a lot of people
understand that it's looking likely that
it might be shuri
but there was an um or based on her
actresses you know internet activity
regarding the the covenant and whatnot i
don't know that's
we'll see what happens there but what
are what's your feeling man like you
know in a world where
you know they didn't ever retire james
bond when a james bond actor passed away
and they've never retired
batman and superman spider-man like
on and on you know we never
here look at it this way chris reeve had
an
accident he couldn't play superman
anymore but they were never like you
know we're gonna stop
making superman do you feel i get why
they're doing it but dude
what's your feeling like yeah like both
both versions of it
make sense to me like i understand the
desire to to make t'challa a bit of a
memorial
to chadwick bozeman and to out of
respect for him to just
leave it alone for a bit but at the same
token like yeah like
t'challa is a character that should be
around for a much longer time
you know that should be on the screen in
a big bad way and at the center
you know of the marvel universe for a
lot of people
including the marvel universe um
and yeah like while we've never had to
recast a james bond because an actor
died
or a batman or or what have you
you know there were new dumbledores you
know and then dumbledore meant a lot to
a number of people
you know maybe not in the same way that
t'challa does but like yeah like sadly
richard harris passed away and we're not
not having a dumbledore
so let's find another guy i mean i think
audiences understand what that is
and can swing with it and to not be able
to tell t'challa stories anymore
feels uh unfortunate you know
in a way that like yes it's all
unfortunate you know nobody wishes the
chadwick had passed and so nobody wants
there to be no more to jealous stories
um but i also understand that in this
story the mantle of the black panther
passes on like black panthers do die in
the sort of you know in in the course of
action so
yeah whether it's shuri whether it's
umbaku whether it's a new character we
haven't heard of
whether you find a way to to
retcon the death of killmonger the way
we've retconned the death of boba fett
and suddenly killmonger can now have
been chastened and discovered that he
has now figured out how to be the black
panther
give me more michael b jordan i'll take
it death doesn't mean anything
um fictionally uh in fantasy
let me do that again i want to see your
your killmonger as the black panther
movie good sir
um somebody in chat uh stephen
courtney said i can't believe you guys
didn't mention black widow in the loki
trailer
i thought i saw an image of that did you
see that
i don't remember it was a quick image of
what looked like
black widow sitting off by herself
or the shape of someone who looked like
black widow
but uh apparently stephen courtney saw
it as well
anybody else in chat did anybody else
see that moment
yeah we're getting a bunch of it now
everyone's confirming black widow in the
soul realm
that's what i thought as i was watching
the trailer i was like are they [ __ ]
saying
that she's there like like does this tie
into a [ __ ] end game
but it looks like it it's and then
christy 84 says
it's not her it's lady loki how do these
people know that now everyone's saying
it's lady loki not black widow
but female loki how does everybody know
this mark and i don't
uh you know it's it's it's one of those
i'm
super invested and knowledgeable about
the movies
not so much so about the comics and i
knew think lady loki comes out of the
books
[Music]
yeah no house of rio says no it was lady
loki
aidan r says lady loki everyone is
saying
lady loki i'm i'm
that [ __ ] excites me man um all right
what else we got
what other news marvelous that is the
end of the marvel news that
what no there has to be more shows
not enough for you you need more shows
oh my god that was
more than enough for me that was uh i'm
i'm not one of those cats it's like both
too many
no way keep it all coming are you
kidding me i'll take a [ __ ] disney
plus should just be
marvel central or star wars central like
and it practically is going to be at
this point is driving most of the shows
during the uh star wars section of
announcements they did reference
willow as well right even though that's
not technically part of the star wars
universe
but they they did confirm that willow
was happening totally
yes they confirmed that john chu is is
going to help oversee it they confirmed
that you know warwick davis is coming
back
and that's awesome and that's really
nice but like
could you imagine being the willow news
on that day
here's our gigantic unfurling star wars
[ __ ]
which never ends it can loop a death
star
20 times and they're like by the way
willow's back as well
well they very wisely did willow before
they did star wars
yes very much so um yeah man it was
it was a day for star wars and [ __ ]
marvel fans and
you know i i i i i'm just delighted that
we've lived this [ __ ] long man these
are dreams mark
these are shows that his children are
like oh could you imagine if they did
this
and mind you we had one like [ __ ]
cart
one comic book tv show when we were kids
at a time batman 66 which was all reruns
by the time i was born and [ __ ]
then like incredible hulk um spiderman
spiderman you know in various times and
then the cartoons and whatnot
but now we live in a world where they're
like we're doing a [ __ ] show about
loki and we're gonna send them all over
the [ __ ] universe
we're doing a show about wanda vision
which is literally like
about [ __ ] uh the vision in the
scarlet witch
and it's gonna lead into the [ __ ]
next feature
in the doctor strange move like i like
it's
i know some people are i always ask me
like don't you want to work on this [ __ ]
i'm like
[ __ ] no i just want to watch it all when
i hear announcements like that
i don't ever go like where am i in this
world like i don't
i don't see myself involved this is the
[ __ ] that feeds me like this is what
entertains me so i can go and try to
entertain
others and [ __ ] so these announcements
man i'm like yes
yes yes there's no part of me that's
ever like man i wish i was doing that
how come not me i'm like you're giving
me all the good
[ __ ] and and you know what it's good and
i'm not involved
keep me out of it then because i want
more of this [ __ ] to come i want this
to be the rest of my life this is where
i get to like hang up
my [ __ ] [ __ ] where i'm like it's time
to go back to being
a member of the audience because the
[ __ ] programming the [ __ ] they're
making is so
[ __ ] good man i'm delighted delighted
by all this [ __ ] news
good for disney plus good for disney um
and there's more
you know like they talked about indiana
jones five which
you know which is huge [ __ ] news oh
my god yes
like uh james mangold is doing another
indiana jones film that
that too was also kind of like the also
ran news of the day
which is saying something if if like
indiana jones 5 is an afterthought with
james mangold the guy who gave us
[ __ ] logan
directing is a kind of afterthought just
think about the embarrassment of riches
that that means we're we're [ __ ]
looking at that's how we got here man
like to the point where we're like oh
yeah
also indiana jones because there's like
[ __ ] nine new shows and projects
that just like our childhood come to
life
so indiana jones coming harrison ford's
coming back um
for a planned 2022 release um
noah holly of fargo and legion fame
is overseeing a new alien series for fx
that's awesome the idea of doing a
series [ __ ] who ain't gonna watch that
yeah and it's set on earth and blends
the timeless horror of the first alien
film with announced up action the second
um ridley scott is also you know
involved in some fashion
hey man if we can if we can use these
shows to retcon can we go back and
[ __ ] bring newt back to life for
christ's sakes
yes we should please be back pixar is
making a toy story prequel
called light year um which is the origin
story for buzz lightyear not the toy
but the man the toy is based on um
we know this because chris chris evans
was very clear
yes about how this is
based on the character not the toy or
whatever the [ __ ]
yeah this is a very uh clever way to get
rid of tim allen isn't it
it seems to be very smart we need a new
buzz
who's somewhat less controversial and
who who don't love [ __ ] chris evans
he puts them sweaters on kisses them
dogs jenny slate we we all [ __ ] lie i
mean not anymore but we all
love chris evans he's america's
sweetheart [ __ ] he's got america's ass
and america's heart so i'm glad he's
doing buzz lightyear indeed
um tiana and moana two disney princesses
are
getting their own spin-off series um on
disney plus
pinocchio starring tom hanks live action
movie is going straight to disney plus
um foregoing a theatrical release
entirely um
raya and the last dragon which is
pixar's next movie
is going to premiere access much like
mulan did
um the disney's next animated movie
after raya
is in kento um sort of colombian fable
um music by lin-manuel miranda
so hey that's cool and finally disney's
developing a new sci-fi animated series
called
iwaju um which will the debut on disney
plus in 2022
in partnership with a small nigerian
group of creators
with a few kickstarters and some
webcomics under their belt named kugali
um who somehow managed to secure a
partnership with the largest
entertainment company in the world
um for a new sci-fi kind of afrofuturism
cartoon which that's pretty [ __ ]
awesome
who's doing it um it's uh this sort of
collective called kugali um
which is a bunch of sort of small-timey
african um
filmmakers and animators who are not
small-time anymore
just that called up to the majors to do
a disney show
um well mark once again everybody's got
a disney show but us
someday soon my prince will come
until then i'm more than happy i don't
believe me i don't need a disney show if
they keep giving us disney shows like
this
i'm happy to be a disney consumer um
you know i've seen a lot of people of
course in the chat who are like we don't
need this we don't need that
um you know some people like we don't
need a [ __ ] prequel to
toy story uh we don't need any of this
[ __ ] kids but
i'm glad some of it exists man it's all
about choice you ain't got to watch it
they're going to make it you ain't got
to watch it but i guarantee you when it
comes
you're going to want to watch it man um
that's what we do
we watch the cool [ __ ] and then we watch
more cool [ __ ]
and then one day we die that is life
great the cool [ __ ] that they're [ __ ]
giving us right now why
uh did disney feel the need to do all
this what is the benefit
in showing us all the nudity like
and even showing the brown eye why did
they
why is there a is end of year
financial thing uh what is the benefit
to
showing all this um the benefit is for
their stock price to go up
um which it has hit a record high after
their investor day um sort of cavalcade
of excellence
when you say record high do you mean new
record high
based on the new normal or record high
including when the parks were open
um i i am not entirely sure give me one
second and let me figure this out i'm
thinking it's the latter because i don't
think they they didn't qualify it by
being like it broke records for the last
year they just said like it broke
records so
they're you know when uh the parks you
know park in florida is open
parks here in california is still not
and whatnot
uh and that's a big part of where they
make their money uh
none of their movies can play at the box
office right now and whatnot
um so you know you would imagine
stock would be in a weird bad place
but after these announcements
to hear the stock [ __ ] go up man like
that's
it just shows you how important disney
plus
is to the disney empire right now yeah
uh
according to this piece on deadline um
it uh it finished at a 175
dollars and 72 cents per share
which is apparently a record high for
the stock it had been at a low
of eighty dollars a share below that um
during the early onset of covid um
you know in the beginning of the year so
march april when they had to start
shutting down parks
um but yes 100 the the
the boom is because of a um the virus
um and the vaccine and the idea that yes
we will be able to go back to theaters
probably by the tail end of next year
tal
khan says kevin stop simping for disney
kids i've been simping since the 90s if
this is simping
i i simp a lot of [ __ ] i simp hard
or to jay-z's new single big symphony
yes
i'm being a big sipping i'm a fan first
and foremost you got to remember that
kids this ain't simpin
i used to work for disney um i certainly
don't need a disney job these days i got
my own thing going on and stuff
but i like what they're doing man this
is where i get to fan out and stuff so
don't tell me not to be simple
this is simp worthy [ __ ] like
after
years of like you know a desert
a wasteland a [ __ ] like uh
entertainment where it's like they give
you one movie maybe two movies a year
and stuff
they're just now taking it out and
golden showering us with all the best
[ __ ] yeah i'm gonna simp dow khan i'm
simping hard
it's simping hard so yeah it is actually
a record [ __ ] man this
this should be called simp man beyond
well fat simp beyond and his buddy
who had more taste than him but we
thought that was a very long title
the simpsons the cs
um you know what uh right now somewhere
else on the internet
i am competing in the uh in the showdown
i hope you're doing well yeah we should
throw people that way are we done do we
cover everything
uh of the disney yes of all the news oh
there's so much more news brother
are you kidding me yeah i talked i maybe
hit the spider-man stuff kind of
but you know the fact that toby mcgiren
andrew garfield and emma stone
and kirsten dunst are probably coming
back and charlie cox as well
there's reaction to the hbo max um
unveiling let's talk about that a lot of
people got very upset with this uh when
when
we we as consumers were like woohoo
we're getting all the [ __ ] warner
brothers movies next year for 2021
and uh i guess they forgot to call a few
people
uh you know it seems that the way they
they
they did the hbo max roll out for wonder
woman was
they called patty jenkins and gal gadot
and they sat them down and says here's
what we're thinking about doing
and they were like yeah we understand oh
by the way here's giant fat
checks to cover the fact that you're not
going to make your back end windfall
that you would have theatrically
and everybody's happy and so they went
ahead and decided to announce it
and then they just said [ __ ] it let's
put everything on
on hbo max and didn't call anybody else
and so like denis villeneuve who
directed doom said hey
i learned the news that warner brothers
has decided to put it on hbo max
on the news you didn't call me to tell
me my movie was going to premiere this
way
i pushed the movie from last year into
the next you know october
thinking we would be out of the
coronavirus by then
and now you're putting my movie on hbo
max
jc what did you say you did you jump
into chat and say apatow made a great
point about that
great point about what about residuals
and and how people earn i think mark you
may have it in there you probably could
speak on it better but
you know a lot of people make money on
back end points
and uh streaming rights are negotiated
separately
so you may take less upfront money for
more back end points
because dune is going to be a billion
dollar box office office thing
and now you're getting measly streaming
points on it
you know yeah from what i understand
what i read
uh patty jenkins gal gadot got like 10
million a p
to buy them out you know on the back end
of one of uh
wonder woman 84. but uh you know they
did not make those same rich offers and
deals
to all the other filmmakers you know i
guess
prohibitive wise or whatever um so
you know denny our one of our favorite
my favorite filmmakers we love them on
this show denny villeneuve directed uh
the dune flick um he came out
hard i i didn't make this
for for this and he like people are
being
filmmakers being very careful chris
nolan of course the most famous to come
out and say
uh you know i went a lot of filmmakers
went to bed working for
the greatest movie studio in the world
and woke up working for the worst
streamer or something like that
which i thought was like unnecessarily
harsh but
um a lot of the filmmakers uh
and and of legendary as well who
co-financiers or
really the lion's share of the financing
for four percent of the money came from
legendary 85
of the money comes from legendary these
cats are saying like
hey this is not a warner brothers
decision this was an
att decision a t has brought warner
brothers
and a corporate decision is being made
here and a lot of them are saying like
you don't understand you've
disrupted the biosphere here
like warner brothers uh filmmakers they
trust
and believe in the studio and you've
superseded the studio
so it's created a bunch of consternation
not just on
you know uh the question of back end
monies and
what goes away if you're just streaming
and stuff but also
in uh the degree of filmmakers you know
a lot of cats who go to warner brothers
are used to releasing movies in a very
big certain specific way and now
their choices have been kind of taken
out of their hands completely and you
know it's i get
why at t and warner brothers doing what
they're doing and stuff
um you know it just feels like maybe
they should have given a bunch of people
a heads up before they made that
announcement because
ever since the announcement's been made
every day there's been a new
story come out where people are like we
didn't know when we're pissed
the biggest one was nolan like that was
huge
for chris nolan to attack warner
brothers by way of
hbo max or to have anything like that to
say it's like colonel sanders attacking
kentucky fried chicken for heaven's
sakes like
he's he's their big gun their big big
filmmaker and if he's out there
making those noises first thing i saw or
thought of when i read his quotes
was like i bet you somebody's going to
netflix pretty soon
yeah you know but it's also there's a
bit of like
you know chris nolan who all but just
browbeat warner brothers into releasing
tennant theatrically
at a time when we 100 knew that you
shouldn't do it
you know maybe you should not be the
dude to talk so much here
you know max i think somebody over there
pointed that out that like look
we're doing this because we took a big
hit on
tenet and no and and i saw a lot of
people online
chiming in about like look man he wanted
his movie back in movie theaters when he
wanted back and he wanted it to save
movie theaters but then it didn't and
now because of that this
led a t who just recently bought warner
brothers and they're not thinking in
terms of
oh 100 years of uh filmmaker friendly
you know studio
uh these cats they're big corporation
and and hbo and warner brothers hbo max
just pieces of their gigantic [ __ ]
pie
so these cats are just like look man
this this is what we can't put movies on
theaters
we just got screwed releasing tenant
let's do this
but um you know
again i i maybe you just
give everyone a heads up before you make
that announcement
make sure they're all on board because
now there's like a lot of
walking back like what happens if
legendary
does sue and they're like we don't want
dune is part of that like denny
villeneuve was like
they're using images from my work to
sell something i did not intend
to sell now that's being you know that's
breathing rarefied air
when it's like at the end of the day you
made a movie and a movie is a commercial
for them to sell their product and the
product is the movie and blah blah blah
so
it was always gonna sooner or later be a
you know
on hbo max or a a you know
used to sell hbo max in some way but
you got it like you got to give people a
heads up before that happens because
otherwise
we're seeing what happens and and like
you know they i if i was if i was them
i'd be like thank god
disney made all their announcements when
they did it changed the conversation
for a minute yeah i mean i think that
that
a lot of it stems to your point of the
fact that at t
does not have to deal with talent that
is not part of their
sort of mandate like they own a giant
you know telecom company
they own streaming companies they don't
have to talk to artists about anything
and so if you had gone to them and said
hey listen gang
here's the reality of the world you know
even if the vaccine starts to get out
you know your average person isn't
getting it until summer and we're not
sure when you can qualify you know
opening movie theaters and who knows how
many of them will be
this is a step we feel like we have to
take but we understand that you're not
going to get the money you're supposed
to get
so here's a bazooka gun full of cash
that we're going to fire into your house
and make you happy with this if things
change then we can re-examine it later
on down the line but right now here's
kind of how we feel
if you just handle people the right way
and you communicate with them
your intent and the reasons for it and
you compensate them the way
that you feel they need to be
compensated nobody's writing angry
letters to anybody nobody's shouting at
their
rafters the gills don't start getting
involved because the guilds don't have
their their
consistency to protect the agents don't
start getting involved because now caa
and icm and ut are all going to start
bringing lawsuits because their
commissions are now at risk
like it all becomes this if you just
called people
and said here's what we're thinking
about doing and paying them we have a
stack of 10 million dollar checks here
to give to all of your stars
none of this blows up this way but att
has never had to manage
talent like this and they [ __ ] it up
it's been a big show so far kids a very
big show with lots of news going on and
whatnot and we promised you at the start
of this very big show
that we had two sponsors uh of course
at the top we told you about our good
friends at
native but right now
we'd like to give a shout out to our
other sponsor
uh for tonight's episode of fat man
beyond ladies and gentlemen mark
tell them who it is it's the good folks
it keeps
you know as guys so much of our identity
is wrapped up in our hair from how it
feels getting a fresh cut to the way
it's perfectly styled before going out
and that's why when we start to notice
uh you know the first sign of hair loss
it feels like panic time
because no guy is ever ready to go bald
but thankfully now there's keeps
the simple and easy way to keep your
hair
you know two out of three guys will
experience some sort of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35 and the
best way to prevent hair loss is to do
something about it while you still have
air left
and so you can do this from home you
don't have to go to the doctor's office
thanks to kids you can visit a doctor
online and get hair loss medication
delivered right to your house
and every three months you can say
goodbye to pharmacy check out lines and
all four doctors visits
um let me tell you as a guy who has been
uh
losing his hair for oh ever i'll never
forget i was in uh
mall rats a picture i don't know if
you've heard of this movie mark but i
was in a little movie called mall rats
back in 1995.
at one point i put my head through the
[ __ ] door
um while swinging around the mall and
[ __ ] joey adams getting
changed inside and uh bam my head goes
through
and uh hat comes off and stuff like that
and
when my mom saw the movie
um my mom uh you know maul rats she said
two things about it
uh jc check the chat uh the text number
one
my mom said um oh oh how nice you got to
run around
you needed exercise that's good um
the other thing she said was tiger
you have a bald spot and it did if you
look in that scene my head goes through
and i had a bald spot that was maybe
about the
size of a quarter at that point uh well
now i'm like
[ __ ] friar tuck and [ __ ] like that so
uh unfortunately i
keeps won't bring new hair but it helps
you keep
the hair you got is that correct easy
could have [ __ ] used back in 1995
is my point man so if you two are ready
to take action and prevent hair loss go
to keeps.com
fat man to receive your first month of
treatment for free
don't cost you nothing that's right
eps.com
batman dude free first month free
what is that uh url again k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash fat man um and they're
gonna get a free
trial they get to put it on and see if
they like it before they even
commit to buying the product for sure
man you'll get your consultation with a
doctor you get your first month
treatment free
if you don't like it cancel go unhappy
and the treatment started just 10 bucks
a month
10 bucks a month dude to keep your
[ __ ] hair is that
it that's it i'm in i i don't have
enough of it
left so heavens man um i i would like to
keep as much as possible so
i'm going to check out keeps for
heaven's sakes put it on the top of my
head
one more time with the url keeps
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash fat man
christopher benjamin is saying no don't
bald don't
bald shame people nobody's bald-shaming
anybody man
but some people like hair so if you want
to keep that air
keeps ladies and gentlemen keeps
treatments typically take between four
to six months to see results so it's
important to act fast the sooner you
start using it the more hair you'll
um keeps we thank them
for uh sponsoring this super
deluxe edition of uh fat man beyond
um ladies and gentlemen if you want to
go see me battle on the shmo down i'm
doing that somewhere on the internet
right now
but uh boy oh boy we still got some news
for yous do we have news or as we are
into q a parts
we we have as much more news as you want
to do's my friend hitting me the news
just keeps [ __ ] coming it's like that
do you see the video of that tree that
those guys like that old tree they cut
open
and water poured out of it for like 10
minutes and [ __ ]
dirty water tree what other news we got
um let's see we talked about that we
talked about spider-man
um brian k vaughn um our friend
uh why the last man brian k vaughn why
the last man in saga brian k
vaughn is writing a new buck rogers tv
show
are you [ __ ] me what a great idea
man that's a concept that can really
[ __ ] play
oh hell yeah hell yeah legendary is
is updating it they're the studio behind
it you know we just talked about
legendary
but [ __ ] brian k vaughn you know
who's got some experience in tv
you know like he was uh he worked on
lost he was the showrunner of
uh stephen king's under the dome he's an
executive producer of why the last man
which is coming soon from fx
um and that dude knows a cliffhanger
like nobody's business so i am super
excited
i'm all for it this is a book roger as
old as [ __ ]
time itself was older than star trek and
whatnot
um we had an incarnation in the 80s that
we all kind of enjoyed
bdbd video oh yeah book but uh with
twiki and whatnot but it's just a cool
concept
um yeah i i've co-signed this man i
think that's a good idea i would totally
watch that show
for sure i mean it's like it was first
published in 1928
in case you're not familiar with it 19
[ __ ] 28 man they were still they were
looking at in outer space
then they really were written originally
by philip francis nolan the story told
of a man who's trapped in a coal mine
during a cave-in who falls into
suspended animation
and rip then we'll wrinkle that rip van
winkle style
wakes up almost 500 years into the
future and there he's enlisted to help
fight a war between several gangs and
what was once america
um the dog says he had the twinkie clock
radio as a kid remember that
oh i loved it [ __ ] twinkie and dr
thermopolis dr theopolis
that's wrong carried him around around
his [ __ ] neck he was the original
flavor flav he carried that clock around
before flavor flav did it was dr
theopolis
um so yeah that is that is on the on the
it's in the kitchen
who knows when that'll be done legendary
will still need to sell it to a network
but um brian k vaughan makes me excited
about things so i'm here
i can't yeah number one tap comic book
people for everything i remember when i
first got in this business people were
like well that's
we don't those are comic book people i'm
like are you kidding me [ __ ] like who
knows how to tell a better episodic
story
than somebody who has to [ __ ] do that
anyway
issues a year and stuff like that but
number two man buck rogers this could
total i mean pun intended could totally
[ __ ] fly
um i'm i'm all on board for that i'm
here for it
um hbo is uh is
currently in early development stages of
rebooting true blood
uh now when we say a reboot of true
blood does that mean brand new
incarnation or
like a follow-up you know check in with
the characters
um you know it's unclear um you know at
this time
i'm gonna say it might be a little too
soon because that only ended what six
years ago
um yeah i did it yeah 2014
was the finale yeah it just feels too
soon for that
um i i you know i like true blood and
it's so [ __ ] modern it's not like oh
that's so dated they need to redo it
if they were doing a uh reboot or in as
much as like uh
you know like what they did with the
connors where it's just like hey we're
just picking up or what they did with uh
[ __ ] uh you know uh will and grace
where they're like we're just picking up
years later and we're gonna tell you a
few stories and
[ __ ] i'd be all for that because i love
that cast but
rebooting just seems like too soon for
that yeah
currently none of the originals cast is
attached to return
so it just seems like let's just tell
more stories in this particular world
and you know for me a bit like you
there's a billion vampire stories you
could tell there's a
hundred thousand vampire novels you
could choose to adapt
vampire is enough of an ip to just do a
brand new thing if you wanted to
i don't particularly feel the the urge
to return to the true blood universe
but that is just me tinnette is that
is the [ __ ] says i never got past the
second season of true blood it got too
sappy
true blood was actually a really good
show man like
it never it never lost me over the
seasons there were some that were
stronger than others some seasons
stronger than others but like
it never devolved to the point where i
was like why did i ever start watching
it
it was worth getting past that season
two man they did cool [ __ ] in that show
but like mark said it's like if you just
want to tell a vampire [ __ ] story
like
come up with a new one man yeah or you
know go to a bookstore
and or amazon or barnesandnoble.com or
someplace online
or a local bookstore near you and just
look up vampire and watch your
search results just keep churning like
just find something else that's cool
you know i mean that the interesting
thing is roberto aguirre sarcasa
and jamie o'brien are attached to
writing executives that's the only
reason why i was
like ooh cause i like uh uh he's the
dude that does uh
sabrina right yeah the sabrina he does
riverdale katie keane
and i interviewed him for imdb a few
times and he's
creative and wonderful and [ __ ] like
that um
so yeah maybe but like it feels
i i i it just i feels kind of too soon
yeah unless it's a sequel series or like
you know [ __ ] like
you know it's new characters but like
hey look bill
came back or whatever the [ __ ] then i'm
i'm on board you know
degrassi the next generation this [ __ ]
um in in slightly to the left of genre
news
nicholas cage is doing the history of
swear words
on netflix which tickled me to no way
me as well and i saw that i was like oh
i'll listen to him explain [ __ ]
uh nick cage one of my favorite
performers ever
[ __ ] live still to this day i'm a
huge fan of uh
valley girl which was his first big
performance
and that that that established uh you
know
one of those actors that uh i appreciate
watching because they make choices
nobody else does
good or bad right all wrong
they make those out their [ __ ]
choices man like that
that make memorable performances nick
cage absolutely one of those guys so i
i'd watch him read the [ __ ] phone
book let alone [ __ ] describe where
the word
[ __ ] came from where the word [ __ ] came
from
uh more nic cage in our lives i say yes
starting on january 5th we're going to
get six episodes in which he details the
origins of
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] dick [ __ ]
and dang and which one damn
[Applause]
um i yeah i mean i'm i'm all for it uh
my only regret is i didn't pitch this
[ __ ] series for i should have pitched
this
like what the [ __ ] but yeah i'm all for
it as long as
it's happening and nick cage is the host
i'm all on board
our last story um is another one of the
sadly we're doing way too many um rest
in peace stories
um but the the great and powerful
tommy tiny lister passed away yes i was
i was trying to remember who died yes
um the president for heaven's sakes
president lindbergh
and luke respect for my president
indeed uh president of uh the fifth
element was that it
yep and uh you know a pretty notoriously
badass
gangster in the dark knight um he'd been
in some 80 some odd movies including of
course the friday films with ice cube as
debo um passed away at 62
no cause of death has been determined
uh i saw that he had had coveted earlier
this year
i just read this morning and that he was
scared or worried that it was
coming back he had survived about with
it or something
um so yeah but i don't know what he
passed from but
um what a what a memorable performer man
yeah i mean he was a professional
wrestler before he became an actor
um you know nobody else in the world
looked like him
and oh my god somebody just said in chat
that kovid took charlie pride last night
yeah charlie pride for those who don't
know is country western singer one of my
father's
favorites kissing angel good morning
amongst other things wow
he passed away of covid jesus
yeah rough [ __ ] year man
um yeah man uh did uh
tiny have anything in the can before you
pass anybody know
um yeah not that uh any of the news
reports mentioned but
hopefully there was something good one
more good thing would be nice
yeah um we have an entire body of work
though
um to look back on it's a shame man
that's six
how old 62. he's [ __ ] younger than my
dad my dad died 67 i thought that was
criminally young
yeah um man oh man what else
anybody else that's the end of the road
near as i can tell
um you know wow there's a lot of love
for charlie pride going on in the
in the uh
yeah it does my heart good to see so
many people not only knowing that cat
but
going like yeah man [ __ ] covert indeed
um all right ladies and gentlemen that's
a
[ __ ] ton of news give it up for mark he
got
through it all we did it you guys all of
us together
he's breathless for heaven's sakes um
all right
let us uh do uh as we always do on this
show
and uh turn to the audience
uh and ask the audience what they
want to know of us the chat has been
very active tonight
jc come join us come to the forum jc
charlie pride we should point out was 86
years old ladies and gentlemen
big bucket of win as we say on hollywood
babylon
what a what a big life but uh didn't
have to end
right now [ __ ] [ __ ] covet
uh richard corbin passed away as well
oh yeah yeah
[ __ ] forgotten also covet
i don't recall um somebody asked for
uh some masters of the universe updates
um i have seen the fully animated
uh episode that mark wrote
three and it is absolutely wonderful i
have seen
um now all the animatics in fact they
just sent
uh a locked animatic for the last
episode and it is phenomenal
um i have heard a lot of uh
music and i'm not allowed to talk about
that and who's composing that music but
i have heard some music and it is
mind-bendingly phenomenal uh it's
feature uh score
great um so can't wait to share
said person is also a future composer so
that makes sense
this uh our composer's been all over the
map
uh but you know what you know we're
working on
an animated series and you'd imagine
that an animated
score would be enough and our composer
has
delivered unto us something that would
sound at home
in a marvel movie for heaven's sake
though uh
or or for others so um yeah it's going
along very smoothly
um i suspect that in
early january there might be
something to share
but you know that's that's just my
feeling uh because uh we're we're at a
place
now where we're seeing a lot of thing
i'm not
we're nowhere near done there's lots
more to do but
we're at a place now where like it
it's no it's far from theoretical i'm
seeing things that like
episode one now is i would say
99 completely blocked
[Music]
so you know you start doing that
that means you're headed towards showing
people things
so uh yeah next 2021 gonna be
the year of grace goal my friend
and back motu is back in a big [ __ ]
i you know it ain't saying much because
i worked on the show so i'm close to it
obviously
um and it ain't saying much because
everything makes me emotional
but i swear to you like i i watch this
show from beginning to end
all the time and just get so
emotionally invested cry i roll tears
tears of joy tears of happiness for the
characters uh
the relationships the developments uh
it's i can't wait for others to see it
man and
if others eventually do see it one day
and be like what the [ __ ] were you
talking about
i'll quit this business if i'm crazy and
i'm seeing a show that nobody else is
seeing
i i will hang it all up but the good
news is the few people
that i've been able to share it with um
who have nothing to do with the process
uh are
like oh my god is this what this is i i
had i know and i would have watched this
years ago so it's very
it feels good i look forward to 2021 for
all the [ __ ] that you announced
uh that we're going to eventually see on
disney plus and whatnot in the movie
theaters
but also for when we get to see uh
masters of the universe revelations on
netflix it is
[ __ ] tight so there's your bit of mo
too uh all right
let's go to it jc we uh ask
they ask us questions we give them
answers give us three
and let us get out of here i will point
out that right now
i am schmoedowning if you want to watch
me
uh show off my big thick and veiny
brainy
for uh trivia and whatnot that's
happening over at the schmodown right
now but right now
here on fat man beyond we got ourselves
some questions to answer jc what do you
get
all right uh never angry man wants to
know
if you were oh no let me do that one
last sorry uh andre rodriguez
spoilers and never angry man your
question is coming up
uh uh andre rodriguez what three
superheroes would you buy
invite over for a holiday dinner
what three superheroes would i invite
over for a holiday dinner
um
can i invite myself to bruce wayne's
because you know he'd have a [ __ ]
hell of a setup
anything i serve is gonna pale in
comparison to what alfred could whip up
you'd have to sit at the other end of
that long table though i'm all for it
man
my voice is loud enough to carry i
talked to him from the other end of a
chippendale
but the question is would you be allowed
to talk to him about batman [ __ ]
or would he be like especially if there
are other guests you can't be like
oh i love what you do as batman and be
like shut the [ __ ] up nobody knows
so maybe you don't want him as a dinner
guest you know what i'm saying maybe you
want him outside making sure people
don't [ __ ] with your dinner
so i'm gonna take you're doing this the
spirit of this question
really i'm i'm really diving deep on it
tony stark
uh because everyone knows he's iron man
so you could talk about it openly and
you could have conversations about his
adventures and whatnot he's
interesting he's funny um so tony
stark's one of them
uh let's see
wonder woman she's old
so you get a lot of history uh you know
she she don't have to come as diana
prince you could just be in her wonder
woman persona
so you could talk about the justice
league you can ask all sorts of
questions about
superman batman that you wouldn't ask of
superman
and batman you could ask her questions
about her of course and whatnot
um you could be like can you use the
rope let's like you know
dessert while everyone's sitting around
and be like let's use the rope and
everyone tells truths and [ __ ] like that
truth or dare with the magic lasso
um you know you could always like just
for entertainment
fire guns at her and she could block
[ __ ] you know so
she's she's the a fantastic dinner guest
great conversationalist tons of [ __ ]
action and stuff like that
um a goddess for heaven's sakes
um and then third so i got a marvel i
got a dc
um
uh uh uh morpheus dream
uh from neil gaiman's salmon [ __ ] he
would be interesting to talk to
and have some [ __ ] to tell you about um
and you know
as long as he didn't bring death it'd be
all good nice
those are my three mark all right um
thor i feel like thor is an amazing
dinner guest especially the sort of
house broken version of thor
but like that's a dude who likes to
party and you get a couple of uh
pints of ale in him and he'll tell
stories to know to no end
he likes to eat too so you know big
banquet and [ __ ]
[ __ ] yes um zatanna oh
good call because i think she's also got
some stories but in case you ever run
out of food you can just magic up some
[ __ ] food by speaking backwards um
and peter parker i feel like
young peter parker is just super eager
to be anywhere
and like if you need a guy to just sit
on the edge of his you just
tell me more stories mr thor like who's
more adorable
than than young tomahaw and peter parker
at a dinner party full of grown-ups
alternate doctor strange
you like the magic call also like [ __ ]
he can make you anything you want
like you could be halfway through what
you're eating you're like you know i
wish i had gotten the lobster
poof yeah really
you could talk to him about surgery and
[ __ ] not just like the multiverse and
[ __ ] you know him being the saucer or
supreme but you could just be like
what's it like
to like cut a dude open and and save a
life and [ __ ] like that
it's like way to bring it down that i
can't yeah thanks a lot he points me at
his shaking candy
all right man i'm sorry what are your
origin it's weird because that's
something in the movies that like
it's just not really a factor anymore
you know what i'm saying like
go over it yeah like the shaky hands
kept him from being the surgeon
but like he got to be so much more so
yeah i almost went wolverine simply for
uh turkey carving purposes
but that felt like a very limited
because he's also very [ __ ]
harassable
and grumpy also a smoker he's chomping
on cigar the whole [ __ ] time
yeah don't need that um i like your
guest list
all right there you go there's our
holiday dinners
jc chainsaw chat said
ant-man the atom and wasp you could feed
everyone for one dollar
that's a great [ __ ] answer you
deserve your own show
uh gerardo ayoya aiolia
aiolia said condiment king for dinner
how did we miss the
[ __ ] we'd be eating ketchup and mustard
sandwiches
salsa [ __ ] burgers and stuff craving
the hunter would have brought us the
finest [ __ ] goose
well i'm a i'm a vegan so i can't have
any of that yeah
well poison ivy could make me a beyond
burger
with her plant abilities true like don't
eat it how could you eat plants you
piece of [ __ ]
zaytana can make you a [ __ ] like
turkey that's not made of meat
that tastes just like turkey and even
gobbles
oh my god she's like this no animal died
for you to eat this turkey it's lab
grown
yes but you still have to kill it
yeah in front of me with magic
wear the helmet of naboo dr fate that'd
be a good guess too
dr vape dr fate dr strange
and dr doom the three doctors
we could do this for hours all right uh
what do we got jc
um also i just want to give a shout out
to all the fat man beyond viewers
uh 7 300 was the total
uh for stand up to cancer last week last
week we did the show that was a benefit
for stand up to cancer we turned on the
donation button y'all we were trying to
get to 2500 you guys
easily took us over 5000 by the end of
the show when uh
as the you know people watched it later
and and repeat airings or
you know later on catching it they threw
more money on to the total of how much
was it jc
uh over seventy three hundred dollars
seven thousand three hundred plus
look at that man that's what you folks
did for a bunch of folks uh dealing with
cancer so
thank you very much for that um all
right jc what else
okay james russell wants to know uh in
light of the new news i know we've done
this before but
who would you guys cast as your
fantastic
four hmm
okay um
you go first mark i'll stop trying to
think
um let's see i think i think we had at
some point
aiko ytd for reed richards
i've seen uh i've seen some some like
boss logic
illustrations of rahul kohli
from bly manor and and i zombies reed
richards and he looks pretty good
um but i did i always liked the idea of
denzel
as reed richards maybe he's a little too
old to be reid anymore but that's still
pretty [ __ ] cool
um anything to get denzel into the
marvel universe man
hell yeah um man
just part of me really wants chris evans
back
can we get that he's he's he's not cap
anymore
and he can moonlight from buzz lightyear
that's true
[ __ ] chris evans um
i don't know okay you go who's your read
not shia labeouf i'll tell you that much
none of the roles
my read i go taika why waititi is reid
okay i think he's mercurial and he's a
good actor and stuff like that
um and reed should be distracted reed
should be played the way that
michael keaton played bruce wayne
remember
his bruce wayne was always like huh yeah
always distracted by something else um
so i go taika um taika
um let's see sue storm
hmm do you do what trang did and
make it a racially diverse family
um i mean
given that my denzel was my read
um but ironically i for some reason anna
de armas came into my head for sue storm
um wow good pull from knives out
but you know i it's
she's awesome and knock knock too yeah i
mean if denzel is my read then i feel
like i won an age-appropriate
sioux storm and that suddenly ages
everything up a little bit
in ways that i don't think he wants so
maybe i don't get to have denzel
because you don't want it to feel quite
so
everybody's in their 50s right
um so i may have to re-examine
my my read pick
i would have gotten oscar isaac but you
can't have him in that and
moonlight you know my oscar isaac love
let's see what chat is saying
uh jessica chastain is sue storm
[Music]
um will ferrell is johnny storm
elizabeth moss is sue storm there's
something i never thought of
uh gosling for reed richards there's a
great idea
but it just feels and i don't i'm not
trying to like you know i know a lot of
people like oh you're [ __ ] being
woken [ __ ] like that but like
here's your chance to like you know
really redefine
the first family of marvel comics you
know and be inclusive
as [ __ ] and whatnot so like i keep
trying to cast
not white you know what i'm saying just
because yeah
i mean like i've oh somebody just
suggests
jim chapman i i [ __ ] this is a good
idea and i never would have thought
about this
seth rogen is ben grimm oh that's strong
that's a good [ __ ] call right there
it's clever
time
that's a good [ __ ] call i like that
man jim chapman
you'd be my casting director on my
fantastic four movie any day
and here i was just going like no white
people but i'm like that's the whitest
guy i know seth rogen
but also to be fair ben grimm should be
jewish
yes he should be and and seth i believe
is
wow that's a good call somebody says
charlize they're on but
you know she's in a lot of stuff uh
she's good
you know of course i've seen the uh
emily blunt
and john krasinski's suggestion uh but
we've seen that
of course that that's that's the that
seems to be the
most popular yeah which you know i get
it um
somebody suggested i mean this is act
right 82 said will and jada
as read and sue now i don't know if
they're being funny or not but like
i wan i would watch will smith be
[ __ ] reed richards that's a pretty
great idea
yeah i mean you and you get you get the
age because will is 50. like will is not
a young kid anymore
yeah but he's that he's a young 50 like
where you know he ain't like a decrepit
50 like me and [ __ ] it's like oh god
he's
that's a young doctor right there yeah
um i for some reason remember he was in
that movie with
was it margot robbie yeah focus
get them back together man she could be
sue storm wow she's harley quinn you
can't let her be sue storm
yeah i was thinking about ruth wilson
alice did somebody say yeah
alice somebody said john melania's reed
richards
because a guy dresses nice
i think right now i'm i'm telling you
[ __ ] uh
seth rogen as ben graham is a genius
piece of casting
yeah i think we can agree on that i'm
i'm here for the will smith version
of reed richards um
i'm here for like the carla gugino
version of sue storm
um what's her name uh uh jessie
smallett was that her name oh jesse
no jesse jesse jesse
yeah jesse is the one from empire the
girl
get her from she could be a phenomenal
oh she'd be great yeah yeah and so
who do we get for johnny uh
johnny notwithstanding that they're
meant to be siblings or whatever
[ __ ] so we should just cast accordingly
yeah i mean the one smart thing the
track movie did was like other adopted
siblings
yeah which made sen i just it's so weird
you say that when they made the
announcement about fantastic four
i was like [ __ ] i i went back and
started
watching the tranq version on
uh disney plus last night i realized
that he had
shown me three quarters of a movie
and the one that i watched last night
was not what he showed me completely
like he showed me his cut and the one
that i was watching last night i was
like i don't remember that i don't
remember this and then i think it was
because that was when people came in and
re-shot
you know what i'm saying right um but
not it's
it's also not like that [ __ ] like oh
my god what an abortion
cinema i was like totally in and totally
watching it
i i think i'm less judgmental when it
comes to like people
take doing different takes on comic book
stuff because as a comic reader i'm so
used to
different writers handling the material
some people take it lighter some people
take it darker whatever the heck
so as i was watching that fantastic
forum like it's not
you know what i would have done but like
i still found it like all right on you
know it's
it's compelling enough for me to
continue watching
um that being said i look forward
to the kevin feige version the
quintessential version of the fantastic
four
all right so back to who is uh
johnny
what is a young what if you go uh
kelly marie tran as sue storm
to give her her shot after
all the last jedi hate that she got you
give her a fair shot
at a starring role in a big blockbuster
and you get
that main guy from crazy rich asians as
johnny
hello you get john boyega to play
johnny storm
give that man a marvel movie um
yeah he's got you know he didn't get uh
to do as much as he could of his spin
but you see him and attack the block you
can see a little johnny storm there
yeah yeah yeah interesting
who about what about doom uh
somebody who was islamic called this
woke-tastic four yes yes
we're going for um let's see
uh who would be our doctor doom
salma hayek
ladies can be doctors too women can be
doctors too
uh let's see
i mean that's not bad too because it
changes the dynamic between her and reid
potentially they could have been like
you know and then sue storm could be the
young woman in in
in will smith reed's life and this was
something that happened
you know back when he was in school he
was you know
involved
[Music]
and because like the you know that the
wonderful
you know doom wears that mask and you
assume it's because he's [ __ ]
horrible underneath but they've done
stories where underneath he's beautiful
he just has like one tiny
little scratch mark or something and
that's his vanity
forces him into it so like having
reed's college girlfriend
from latveria you know go on to the
reed's arch nemesis
as dr doom as you know woman that's
[ __ ] dope dude
i like that alright so wait who do we
cast
maybe there's your charlize theron right
there she plays bad really well
i still go seven hike that's just my
that's just me
but charlize could do that i mean
angelina jolie could do that
[ __ ] jessica chastain could do that
angelo
angelina joe lee i hadn't thought about
her um
uh carrie washington can do that
i like it but it feels like it it that
feels like if you're doing it as a
a woman and she's like aristocracy or
[ __ ] royalty from europe
that seems feels vaguely european and
hence kind of white no well
i mean i suppose latveria can be
wherever we want it to be it sounds
yeah at the end of the day i'm like no
mark don't you understand it's in europe
it's where all the white people are yeah
i don't know if you've ever heard of it
it's like connecticut
what about what about now she played uh
she was
uh mary i was going to say marion
cotillard but she was already
she was already a what's her name uh
razakul's daughter talia but she could
play in another world
she get 100 slide over
um [ __ ] i was just thinking about some
other friend ooh
now too old isabelle who bear
wow um
somebody said liv tyler is dr doom
that's a choice she came from uh
a series very successful series of
gigantic movies
oh my god uh sean cisco pointed out too
late
carrie washington was already in
fantastic four remember she played
alicia masters
that's right in love with ben graham
orville nation said there are also many
african europeans yes
yes we know we know uh we were just
doing the traditional thing eva green
oh she'd be good yeah i'm trying to
think of european like actress
that she's you know i'm so
america-centric i'm trying to think of
like
oh um
uh what was her name who did i may
destroy you
oh michaela cole [ __ ] she's good actress
man make her dr doom
oh that'd be great um all right
boy that guy we got a lot of [ __ ]
mileage out of that and it's so weird
because we could just toss off a bit
like oh these people
move on but you we literally go silent
going
who you're trying to [ __ ] figure [ __ ]
out
um all right jc we got a final question
all right last question never angry man
wants to know
if you were to write the finale of the
year 2020
what would be the last scene and what
song would you put
taking you into the end credits all
right hold that thought because
obi-wan yourobi wrote in chat
dr doom sasha baron cohen
what a good idea such a good idea if
you're not doing lady doom like we were
doing
yeah [ __ ] sasha baron cohen is a
really [ __ ] great actor
all right back to the question go ahead
okay so you're gonna write
the finale the last scene for the movie
of the year 2020.
what is the last scene and what song do
you put in
that brings you into the end credits
um it is the same last scene from
from uh fight club as the [ __ ]
skyline
starts blowing up and falling down and
we play
uh where is my mind
i'm not very original i'm just gonna
steal from david fincher we all loved it
when he did it in the 90s let's steal
that
yeah i'm just gonna steal the last scene
um from trading places
um but instead of just smiles and
champagne
it's uh it's a like a [ __ ] atom bomb
going off in the water
he's like feeling good louis looking
good billy ray
[Music]
wait i'm gonna do you one better i'm
gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna change my answer
is i'm still gonna steal a movie i'm not
gonna create my own why would i do that
i've never had an original thought in my
life um
i want my ending of 2020 to be the
ending of scrooged
i want to be standing there giving a big
[ __ ] speech
giving people hope making people chuckle
um and then you know uh
credits and they could play [ __ ] uh
uh what was the song put a little love
in your heart
the one that was al green and uh um
what's her name annie lennox right
put a little love in your heart as i
after i give a big speech
and say you could find a person out in
the street and say oh by the way
here that kind of [ __ ] uh i
i think i now want to steal um
idris alba from uh
from pacific rim at the end of our time
at the end of our hope we stand here
together
we are cancelling the apocalypse nice
and then [ __ ] immigrant song plays
out
um i like that one too man uh we got a
good suggestion here and made me laugh
jason mckibben said star wars ending man
give out medals
we should [ __ ] for everyone that
survived 2020.
it should be live long-ass [ __ ] medal
ceremony
and even
in chat says all along the watchtower
starts playing as the cylons descend
down to earth
yeah no
no no we don't 2020 has been bad enough
we don't want it to end with [ __ ]
cylons
now we had a good run you guys
um well that's it kids we've answered
three questions
didn't we that is a show morris code
said last scene from planet of the apes
just replaced the statue of liberty
with some amc signage
wow that got dark
dow khan says play rock with you rock
with you like [ __ ] michael jackson i
wanna
rock with you um
[Music]
do not make money there you go kids
somebody finally said it on the internet
well done i think our woke movie is
going to make lots of money though
yes um don't tell black panther yeah
really there it is ladies and gentlemen
[ __ ] uh we had a lot of news
i got my mando coin
standing by ladies and gentlemen uh for
how much news that we had
uh boy oh boy so much to look forward to
did you have a good time tonight kids
um we want to thank our sponsors uh
not just the good folks at native go to
natived-o-d-e-o
dot com uh but also the good folks at
keeps
indeed um what is their url k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash fat man there it is ladies
and gentlemen thank you for the
the folks at keeps and to the folks at
native for sponsoring the show thanks
to all of you for hanging out and and
spending uh this saturday evening with
us man boy we got through
a lot of stuff and it was a lot of fun
um there ain't nothing to get through
if it were up to me i'd i would be
i'd be newsless the only reason we got a
collection of news
is because that guy's sitting over there
give it up for mr mark bernardin
oh thank you everybody and that
ladies and gentlemen is fat man beyond
for this week uh i'm kevin smith
i'm mark bernard uh tune in next time
same
fat time same fat channel smodcast.com
or
youtube.com kevin smith disney plus
forever
this is the way
you